[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
tasty that is wonderful it's a little
Moroccan green tea really a little
Moroccan that's what I guess is it's got
green tea and mint but that movie Babel
sucked so that's true
also I don't like that you Moroccans
refuse to shake hands at the Olympics
with the Jews come on now we should all
be better than that that's a real story
look it up all right today is a special
stream it's the the Kyle Rittenhouse
live stream yes so we have opening
statements today the jury was seated
which I assume means that they were all
women and had to use a bathroom oh
that's not true at all I you don't know
that have you seen every juror yes I
have you have every single one I saw the
juror with Alec Baldwin back before he
was killing people oh well he killed
people in that that's true he did I
thought it was acting joke's on us he's
a great Methodist he was a training so
all right I'm gonna introduce everyone
really quickly because I don't know when
they will start their opening statements
uh first off let me let you know that uh
yeah we're starting a little early today
please tweet this out smash the like
button right now if you were on YouTube
we want you to comment along with us
also if at any point smash it there you
go if at any point you lose this stream
today which could happen because we are
going to show you videos from the Cal
Rittenhouse situation I'm going to give
you a timeline now the New York Times
has used this quite a few channels on
the left have used this and they are in
fact not age restricted however in the
past we have been and sometimes when
you're live that results in getting
booted yeah you can go over to rumble
the stream is not stopping until I tell
you or of course join mug club uh I'll
let you know when it's done yeah so
don't just be like well I guess they
ended it without clothes no no no no
we'll give you a sign off uh before that
Gerald a how are you I am well and I am
ready for this sir you ready I am ready
you're you're ready to go this thing
pissed me off and it's been pissing me
off for a long time you're champing at
the bit I am how are you people no it's
Champion it's not champing champing is a
whole it's an equine term you don't know
I think it's evolved Urban centers uh
quarterback
sir I'm okay don't answer him
better be careful Garrett's gonna take
it out on someone get you you're over
here on this side all right how you
doing quarterback I'm doing good I'm
ready to get my boy off man whoa no no
no no no no
no no no stop stop whoa okay uh Dave
Landau who will be appearing at the
Cotillion in Wichita Kansas on November
11th Ahoy how are you sir I'm excellent
come out to the Cotillion they're the
ones that were like hey come over here
we're not gonna put in all these silly
mandates be a nice Cotillion wine mixer
so bring a mandate they said hey that's
what I was gonna do oh we're watching
this live channel on court TV uh they
haven't started the opening statements
yet so I want to give you a brief
timeline here here's the issue with Cal
witness let me give you my opinion
I think the kids uh I I don't think the
kid did anything wrong I think the kid
is a hero and I think this has Grave
implications for everyone out there
there have been threats that if he gets
if he you know he walks there are going
to be riots listen there are going to be
riots anyway I think they'll be worse of
course if he walks but this isn't this
is an attempt to intimidate the jury
this determines right now
whether you are allowed to defend
yourself and your property because we're
going to go through what happened in
Kenosha the city was Ablaze places were
being bombed and the cops couldn't do a
damn thing and so there was a kid who
even if you think let me be really clear
even if you think Kyle right now
shouldn't have been there okay let me
ask you a couple questions
before I go to a timeline here Cal
Rittenhouse isn't there okay
the city's been bombed out it's not even
a big city keep in mind Kenosha you're
talking about a relatively small town uh
the city's been a little Blaze over a
false premise by the way this was all
started by Jacob Blake who raped his
wife went back violated restraining
order tried to kidnap the kids reach for
a knife was shot okay let's just be
clear about that so total horseshit
anyone who tries to tell you that this
is because of uh police brutality
against unarmed black civilians he was
armed and he had a criminal record Jacob
Blake this was used as an excuse to burn
down the town
what do you do
in other words if people shouldn't do
what Cal Rittenhouse did if people
should not protect their businesses or
even enlist the help of fellow American
citizens who have any degree of training
or ability to defend life limb property
what do you do
you just let it burn you let it be
another chest then the follow-up
question let's assume that you believe
caloric now shouldn't have been there
that it was a mistake why did he go
there in the first place okay let's
assume it's a mistake
is it a mistake that a 17 year old boy
should be executed for because none of
that is relevant to the point that shots
were fired people were trying to kill
him
that's not even in question it's just
okay uh did he defend himself with an
appropriate degree of force look it is
no longer relevant
if he has a gun charge card people
trying to say and we'll go through the
lie some of the lies he brought a
firearm across state lines that's not
true it was completely illegal for him
to have a firearm that's not necessarily
true there's a loophole on the law and
this everyone who hunts in the midwest
knows this is the case there are a lot
of coloring house shot first that's not
true so the question comes down to even
if you think it was a mistake well I
don't think he should have been there
is that a mistake worthy of death
on the flip side I think telling someone
you're going to kill them chasing them
chasing them or as a person number one
uh chasing them as person number three
with a gun trying to execute him Point
Blank I think that you at least deserve
it you at least deserve a 223 in the
bicep that's me Mr old-fashioned
so yeah I'm gonna go through the
timeline and I know Dave had some
questions yeah he cut this I'm trying Mr
right I'm holding in I'm letting you do
it for me I I I you know I bet it all
well so hey you have a timeline that
you're going to go through and I want to
go through that but you said something a
minute ago and I want to just interject
one thing right so it wasn't the police
brutality it was the media portrayal of
the situation right with Jacob Blake the
media put out there another black man is
shot by cops the media pushed that
narrative before any of the known facts
until you saw the video and it's like
wait he was being told not to go around
the car he was being ordered by police
officers no no no no no he was called
there by the baby mama or wife he raped
exactly right none of this training
order yeah does her life matter none of
it I guess I guess it doesn't none of
this information was made public the
media basically ran with the narrative
that the police have shot another black
man and of course people are running
into the streets not checking for the
updates yeah not checking for
Corrections so even and also in the
movie the juror when Alec Baldwin
intimidates Demi Moore this is a bit
like that it's a little bit like that
of melanin you could watch that let me
hear what this judge is saying right now
uh yesterday he was doing Jeopardy
questions and if it's not that important
I'll give you a timeline and then we'll
go to listen to him calls for they can
do so but until they do that I don't see
the Bears uh why that should be in the
jury instruction we don't have the
self-defense in the jury instruction
okay that's how much are instructions so
token out you can have them let me know
when it's a good time to go there all
right let me give you a timeline because
a lot it's really hard to understand
there's Cal Rittenhouse and there are
three people he shot two dead one in the
bicep just to be clear this all started
uh the Kenosha riots Jacob Blake August
25th two days uh after Blake shooting
let me take you back in time really
quickly and then rapid fire the timeline
foreign
[Music]
mostly peaceful very peaceful yeah they
were cold in August
it's really burning down those prices
huh by the way that was the courthouse
that this Five Below more like 50 above
I'm mad Marv yeah all right and uh hey
by the way really quickly too we are
going to issue the Cal ringhouse
challenge later we are going to put our
employees in that exact same situation
see if they're able to with Nerf guns
mind you yeah first see if they are able
to quote I'm saying so at that last
scene that was the courthouse that this
judge is sitting in today I mean an
insta house was attacked oh but no no
might come back to bite you sir wait
this is literally the same Courthouse it
literally the courthouse the the
peaceful protesters uh bumped into it
shall we say well they wanted to burn
the justice system down to be clear and
now they're demanding that Justice be
served through a justice system that
really just means uh put someone behind
bars so we don't like okay so before we
go through this people saying oh he
traveled there Kyle writtenhouse he was
looking for trouble okay
across state lines
picture your daily commute to work where
he went first off he was a lifeguard in
this community across state lines is
probably less far than your commute to
work yeah anyone who lived in Michigan
right Illinois and all of these places
or Ohio depending yeah you know state
lines really don't mean anything it's
not like this guy went on a trek he
wasn't Lawrence of Arabia
Kenosha he didn't get on a plane right
and check a gun so he was there to clean
up graffiti there's video uh of this
there's uh there's there are interviews
uh he was oh we actually have an
interview beforehand and this again the
context matters where Kyle uh was
showing off his medic kit discussing why
he was there these are events before the
shooting unfolded here's an interview
you doing out here obviously you're
armed and uh you're in front of this
business we saw burning last night so
what's up so people are getting injured
and our job is to protect this business
and part of my job is also helped me
really there's somebody hurt I'm running
into Harm's Way that's why I have my
rifle because
easy there at Furlong we're protecting
from the citizens and I just got pepper
spray by a person in the crowd so you
had non-lethals but you just respond we
don't have non-lethal so you guys are
full and ready to defend the properties
yes we are okay now if I can ask can you
guys step back medical EMS right here
sharp little guy looking for somebody to
shoot he's one of the worst Shooters
we've got so
um so high and not caring if I was 17. I
know yeah it's uh yeah and you know what
that's what we want to encourage he was
high on pepper spray we want to
encourage pretty much I am high on life
because I think he's going to well I
think Justice will be served
um let's be clear too the rioters not
protesters the rioters writers we're
trying to keep in mind they just burned
down a car lot they had burned down Five
Below I don't know why
their prices are tremendous terrible I
show up there I'm like what a tum a
thermos tumbler I do need this yeah if
you took the whole place in San
Francisco totally legal yes completely
legal it's still all under that but they
still you know what it wasn't
necessarily legal when they were trying
to these peaceful protesters blow up a
gas station tale of the tape
come on
this is the thing where because later
it'll come up where they were trying to
say he might have committed arson in a
dumpster no they lit a dumpster on fire
and tried to push it towards a gas
station this is Kenosha let's not call
it a dumpster right quick update about
the trial right now they're talking
about trying to throw out the gun charge
again oh oh really you want to hear what
they have to say no I don't really need
to necessarily hear what they have to
say because that's not a big issue what
you need to understand is let's say
there's a gun charge first off it's not
the gun charge that the media has made
he didn't cross any lines with a firearm
if you think that he was one year too
young with a long rifle and don't
understand there is there's a little bit
of gray area with that law and you think
that justifies putting him away for
murder then you don't understand how the
law Works keep in mind they push that
dumpster fire actual dumpster fire was
Richard come true
[Music]
he was trying to tell the police they
couldn't what are you saying
I don't understand what you're saying
you wanna A Douglas first
over here now we're bringing his
brother's Swedish Chef to explain
[Applause]
keep in mind Rittenhouse was seen not
shooting at people at that point gas
station running with what a fire
extinguisher here you go
what was it fire extinguisher yeah there
you go and this is all important by the
way because when we go through shooting
someone in the bicep and clearing a jam
as opposed to hitting them in the body
or the head it just shows it would be
like uh it would be like a current UFC
Champion Francis and ganu yeah showing
up with protesters and he just held them
down until the police arrived there he
could knock all them out he could hurt
them this kid had the training and the
Marksmanship to do a lot of right there
if he wanted to if he was a mass shooter
if he was someone who was looking to
harm people you will see throughout the
series of armed conflicts that he was
much more effective than other people
there instead you see him with a medic
kit you see him cleaning graffiti you
see him with a fire extinguisher right
there would be easy pickings now
Josh uh sorry Josh Joseph Rosenbaum he's
the person who was killed uh the the
ginger uh serial pedophile when I say
this by the way today if you have
children they shouldn't be watching this
show just gonna let you know because we
are not bleeping out words we are not
editing out this content it's important
for you to know
um Joseph Rosenbaum who was making
threats he's a Serial child molester
what I mean anally raped children yeah
yeah okay
was yelling also uh repeatedly big fan
of the n-word at the gas station
don't you just love how that guy in the
Kaepernick Kaepernick afro is incredibly
confused sooner's like yeah yeah shoot
meaning oh wait a second hold up short
stuff huh they should have just beaten
him yeah well yeah I would have agreed
with that they didn't that's the thing I
showed restraint all the way through
this what do you think the black lives
matter activist would have done if Kyle
Rittenhouse repeatedly yelled the end
that's not just a guy yelling the n-word
that's a balding Ginger short man
yelling the n-word hey well he did a
you're not Ginger tall people say it too
he did it with a soft bar not the heart
what doesn't matter so it's not
freestyle rapping it
he's yelling in a crowd of black lives
matter it makes no sense they don't care
this is the point of the selection I
know I get that yeah no you're
absolutely right the guy the guy in the
Kaepernick afro just sitting there
saying I guess well when our side says
it when I like looked over to see who
was yelling at and he's like I guess you
see the look on his face he's ready to
be offended and yeah oh it's wonderful
keep in mind and they threw this out a
lot of people are mad that they said you
can't refer to these people who were
shot as victims you can refer them as
arsonists and looters because they're on
camera doing it the judge yeah however
they did throw out using the criminal
record uh you know of Rosenbaum against
them right right the defense using it
but I think this is relevant this is
just where I'm not I'm not a I'm not a
lawyer
um Rosenbaum is the kind of guy the guy
who was shot who would have to be
separated from the main population in
prison because they would tear him limb
from limb he's a Serial convicted child
rapist
so let's keep that in consideration
because when he was making threats and
when he was involved with arsenary he
decided to make good on his threats it's
not the fact that he said the n-word
look every time I sing along to college
uh Kanye's College Dropout and I'm
driving huh we're uh we're all guilty I
hate surprises you every time when in a
Ford Expedition the point is
you gotta well look this is a man who
even prisoners would believe is scum and
he happened to attack somebody I would
be so fired as a prison guard yeah I'd
be like hey guys I opened cell block
three yeah that day cameras don't work
there either yeah free chili tokens to
whoever makes it first
two scoops of potatoes for whoever gets
to a person and a pack of cools
cigarettes and Honey Buns
okay writtenhouse also let's be clear uh
I don't know what what this clip is a
lot of people don't know this
writtenhouse did not fire the first shot
he was being chased by Rosenbaum that's
what's happening in this club okay he
was being chased by Rosenbaum Rosenbaum
threw something at him while Kyle
Rittenhouse is running away this is the
first armed conflict and then somebody
else uh you can find the name of that
other uh gentleman what's his name uh oh
Josh Josh zaminski fires around into the
air allegedly but you can hear it only
then does Cal Rittenhouse turn around
say oh this is the guy threatening me
yelling me shoot me inward shoot me
Inward and he's chasing me and I'm just
I'm hearing a gunshot I don't know that
anyone here would have done any
differently yeah if you did if you did
act any differently
it's stupid if someone is chasing you
who's been making threats and someone
who has been violent and someone who
committed committed arson or he's
chasing you you feel something hit your
back and you hear a gunshot fired you
have a rifle on you that is the entirely
appropriate time to defend yourself okay
uh let's go to this clip so you now see
how this started hey boys there's
Rittenhouse running boom guy throw
something hits him
gunshot
and then he shoots first gunshot was not
writtenhouse four were him
get back
and he comes back to check on him comes
back to check on him he calls his friend
in other words he's not running right
now he's trying to make sure that he's
okay right he has his Medicare laid him
out your phone call yeah not exactly a
mass shooter this is not a mass shooter
at this point again if he wanted to do
damage this is something he could have
been not saying that no mistakes were
made what I am saying is come on now
talking Murder in the First Time not at
all is that Kyle helping the man with
his shirt no that was somebody else Kyle
circles back around the car to see what
happens
he sees him on the ground he he makes a
phone call but two people are already
assisting the guy right right and then
they tell him to leave that's not the
only guy that's chasing Kyle so right
now Kyle puts his life in danger by
circling back to check on the person
that was trying to get him right and
then he has to get out of there because
there are other people now this is what
the New York Times said was a mistake
where they said well then he ran with
his firearm back through the crowded
area so that's what uh you know if you
see a crazy guy with a gun hold on a
second his choice now at this point is
run away to where more protesters are in
a remote area right or run through as
public and as crowded up a street as
possible without your firearm in an
aggressive position and Hope that people
police officers which is who he
surrendered to immediately yeah or your
allies are there to protect you
otherwise it could be a death sentence
and he's already been chased and he
heard shots fired right now as he is
running away other rioters chase him
yelling get his ass right before Kyle
fell down here we go
there he is
Sucker Punch doesn't fall yet
more people chasing him a street of
Peace like The Walking Dead for crying
out loud balls down boom guy hits him
ahead with a skateboard okay now that's
the guy he first shoots the guy who hit
him in the head of the skateboard boom
shot in the chest this other gentleman
right here
so to be clear hit ahead with a
skateboard falls down hitting heavy
skateboard shoots that guy in the chest
the next guy who uh let's go through
this uh let's go through the screen
screen overlay so I can freeze frame
yeah yeah so the first one he fell to
the ground okay there he is falling to
the ground now rioter swarm him okay you
can see Ryder swarming him then you have
Anthony Huber attacked him twice with a
skateboard and tried to take his gun
there you go foot stomp skateboard
trying to take his gun next image
Rittenhouse shoots him while laying on
his back right there then
um gross Cruz is the other guy who was
uh I believe he's also charged well he
is charged with a firearm offense he
charged again this guy with a handgun do
we have that or we have the uh video is
it a still I got a video okay here's the
video now to be clear he also puts his
hands up Kyle clears the jam
and then he fakes him out and he goes
and he shoots him look there you go boom
gun right there right up on him we have
another image of him within a foot of
Cal Rittenhouse let's show the clip clip
Jay
that's where he shoots him in the bicep
see you again see the gun right there
Play It Again they're in slow motion
Garrett quarterback Garrett
see so right there that's the firearm
only when he's shot in the bicep is he
no longer a threat right let me see if
it's in here too it's gonna be a better
I might have a better angle yeah
when he goes down you see the lights at
the End of the Street that's that's
where he's trying to get to yeah he's
trying to get to the police that's safe
so there you go right here boom this guy
hands up kind of scared and uh Kyle puts
his gun down now I'll rewind real quick
couple of frames there now go through
this frame by frame look shoot boom guy
puts his hands up okay like he's kind of
scared it's more of a reaction so now
Kyle aims at him he's saying no no no no
wait look Kyle puts his gun aims it back
to the ground do you see that aims it
away from him so the guy goes hey hey
you can see in the video Kyle puts his
gun down yeah and then returns it up to
fire this is important here you can go
off that clip this is important because
anybody who is shot at the range knows
how much easier to go it is to go Target
Target Target Target then to practice
drawing and Target it's something
everyone who owns a firearm responsible
Firearms uh responsible firearm owners
he practice it every time you should be
anyway yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna call the
guy bicep guy just for ease yes bye so
biceps he's alive right though yeah he's
lost 80 of his biceps
CNN was using him as like their poster
child for this like you survived you
tried to stop the guy whatever he's yes
he's a Survivor you see in the video
where he does this he's got the gun in
his right hand he hears a shot he does
this and then he doesn't just approach
Kyle he tries to circle around Kyle's
back so that he can't see him absolutely
and Kyle spends to get him because the
guy is drawing his gun to execute him
Point Blank right now let me really
quickly go to um Courtney Smith's
motions ahead of opening statements all
right we'll get to it as soon as hold on
let me just wrap up the timeline and
then I want to bring it all in because I
want people it's really here's let me
just kind of explain something to you
CNN and MSNBC assume Their audience are
morons then you have a lot of people
these Think Tank conservative
Republicans who assume that everyone is
a hyper-intellectual who works who's a
tenured professor I know that you
watching some of you listening on audio
you guys can listen wherever you listen
to your audio podcast Android Apple
Spotify you're smart you're sharp but
you don't do this for a living
you don't 24 hours a day follow the news
and so I just want to make sure because
that's confusing for me sometimes with
all of these players especially in the
chaos the fog of what's bordering on a
civil war
um so that's what I think of you I think
you guys are smart and I don't think
that everyone is professional talking
head and I'm trying to give you a
timeline here so after all this Kyle
Rittenhouse immediately runs to the
police officers that's hands up saying I
just shot somebody what do you want me
to do
foreign
so keep in mind this reveal say oh he
was only uh he was only not shot because
he was white but we just saw this in
Arlington as well it's no it's entirely
the posture with the police officers
if you run up to the police put your
hands up
and approach them in a surrending uh
surrendering manner
they will treat you appropriately
hands are up
you forgot self-defense yeah well
details
details baby details
we'll see
his hands are up the cops at one point
here yell get out of the street
I think there's a guy in one of those
houses like I ordered a pizza two hours
ago
dominoes you should give me money I know
really
everything
again police see a man with a firearm
who could have done damage already Sans
are up and his hands are up even then
when he walked into the car look his
hands are up repeatedly so let me give
you the timeline really quickly Kyle
this is where he works he was there
cleaning up graffiti he was there as a
medic he was trying to put out fires we
have the shooter uh sorry we have the
person who was shot the attacker the
arsonist uh Rosenbaum one of them
earlier on in the day repeatedly making
threats yelling out racial epithes which
really doesn't bother me just it should
bother the media I'm a little a little
bit murky on the double standard
man chases him later when he finds him
alone throws something at him someone
else fires a gun he shoots him checks on
him tries to make sure he's okay flees
runs gets mobbed chased thrown to the
ground hit in the head with a skateboard
twice shoots that guy puts his gun down
clear as a jam and only when the last
guy approaches him with a gun Point
Blank shoots him in the bicep Mr ulnar
nerve and then surrenders himself to the
police there you go I just told you
everything you need to know all
references available at ladder with
creditor.com and in the description so
you understand
what happened and then I have some more
information here and some common myths
that have been told by the media which
are untrue but I'd like to bring you
guys in does that does that does that uh
you guys can comment below that pretty
much uh sums it up protecting a business
you you said that we want to throw that
back in the timeline protecting a
business making sure it doesn't get
burned to the ground yeah but something
that he did like I have no idea how he
had the kind of control that he did
Sitting on the ground wheeled around a
guy putting his hands up puts the gun
down clears the jam comes back up the
same guy who had faked him out tries to
kill him he shoots him there's a guy
behind him running up yeah that's the
guy that if I was in this situation my
heart was pounding I would have shot him
too yeah he's running up but then as
soon as he sees the guy gets shot in the
bicep he puts his hands up and stop and
Kyle puts his gun at him ready you know
what Society is not he just said your
heart was pounding and I had a joke that
I was about to make and on YouTube I
can't make it because it would be
reveling the death of someone uh I can't
tell you how I feel to watch a Serial
child rapist attacking somebody I can't
express to you no what I believe about
that situation because YouTube considers
it a problem yeah
I don't understand I mean this this is a
clear-cut case like literally all you
have to do on the defense is play the
video yeah all right so he was and we'll
go through this later on but oh so how
screwed would this kid have been if
there's no video oh no this is this is
why this is so scary this is as
clear-cut of an example of self-defense
as you get with video and there's still
an argument about it do you think this
kid would have been allowed to plea his
case that he shot black lives matter
activist do you think anyone would
believe him if he's no this guy repeated
they said you're a racist who shot you
would say but I shot a white guy a shot
of Ginger who yelled the n-word they'd
go please that doesn't happen he had a
BLM t-shirt hey quick update the opening
statements will begin soon the jury has
just entered okay all right Dave you had
a question oh I don't remember okay no I
I don't remember at all I yeah I didn't
know that someone else fired the first
shot no I actually had uh I'll be
perfectly honest I had never seen that
full video yeah
um
I it it uh good luck America what do you
do what do you do if you're that kid and
you're getting swarmed hitting head with
a skateboard and the guy's approaching
you with a gun what do you do the only
defense they have is why were you there
I think and which is obviously what he's
using
um
uh I why were you there let me go to the
tape your honor I'm not saying I'm that
gas fire that's Five Below let me draw
you to the uh to the used car lot hey
have you been a Target recently no you
haven't that's burned down too let me
just this is why Kyle Rittenhouse was
here let me get my laser pointer all
right gas fire right there well that's
just a math fire but Kenosha you know uh
so uh we've all been affected from the
opioid crisis I could use some right now
you know what I'm saying uh and I
believe my client should be free to go I
know this is a crazy this is just insane
when you wonder why why the cops passed
him when he was putting his hands up
because there was some more violence
going on down the road
yeah by the way six cars what are you
gonna they're not all gonna stop for one
guy during a riot and people tried to
argue they've tried to argue well why
weren't they arresting these uh armed
militia members the police chief was
very close to No One including black
lives matter protesters no one was
peacefully protesting was arrested that
night for abusing curfew right only
violent people yeah were arrested so
let's just stop trying to use the race
argument New York Times has that person
going I saw that they was white and I
believe that they were here because they
wanted to kill black people well you
know he shot a ginger that's the
opposite of what you're saying it's like
a picture and a photo negative You
couldn't possibly get more opposite of
going in to shoot black people everyone
in the shop was white everyone who shot
was right but here's the next thing the
media doesn't mean this right the media
is bookended it they over blew the Jacob
Blake situation didn't tell you the
truth that led to all these rights then
they come in and say white shooter
carrying gun across state lines there to
kill people basically yeah but then you
have pieces of like Joseph
Rosenbaum who's getting that's the kind
of guy who gets played by the media who
runs out and thinks like well I'm going
to be a hero now yeah because he's
trying to make up for the years of
pedophilia and child abuse this is gonna
be like a like a dry eraser for all my
having sex with kids yeah this is uh
it's just it's like my Penance you know
what is the guy oh oh you rape one kid
you two kids you raped three kids all of
a sudden you're a child molester for
life
so here's the thing I would have to go
to the worst area of town to throw a
nickel and hit as many violent criminals
as Kyle Rittenhouse shot uh so Rosenbaum
the main guy in question sexually abused
five children what and I know what
you're saying why was he there how about
that question yeah why wasn't why being
a sodomized in prison yeah yeah uh why
wasn't he role playing a 9 or 11 year
old in prison honestly why was he out
why is that acceptable yeah well he just
left a mental health facility so he
anally penetrated a minor showed
pornography to a minor engaged in oral
sex with a minor masturbated for a minor
and he was released on the day of the
shooting from the hospital after
attempting suicide oh hold on and these
are both this is not these are boys from
9 to 11 years old this is not like a
boyfriend who was 18 and his girlfriend
this guy anally raped a miner doesn't
say because the this information
sometimes is sealed from it nine to
eleven and he sexually abused
five miners hey hey what point do we
start protecting our kids yeah and I
don't just mean from puberty blockers or
as you call them Flintstone vitamins you
prick so why why was he released from
the hospital is there any information I
don't know what was he but was it
because of the riot because that would
show you a very interesting maybe
covered like ah he had the sniffles go
out don't rape any more kids now
we don't want him to get sick no oh gosh
uh if they were me I would be blowing
ricin into his face like a powdered
sugar donut yeah five times
I meant to give him uh his medicine but
I actually gave him a bunch of poison I
have no idea I don't know how it
happened then I made him uh I made him
go up on the front stage at a Pantera
concert yeah what it was look there's
your hero yeah so Anthony Huber is
another gentleman here who shot
strangled and stabbed his brother
threatened his grandma and brother with
a knife now we have this is overlay K2
gauge crows crouts slew of misdemeanors
including misuse of a dangerous weapon
and uh he had a gun of course when he
attacked Kyle reckon Rick and Rick John
Hickenlooper it's my head's on Richard
painter yeah
so um I don't know if we need to go
through a bunch of these they try and
claim now that he was a white
supremacist we'll go through a New York
Times video later he was seen flashing
white supremacy uh symbols likes he said
okay once yeah yeah yeah no he uh he had
apparently seen the cover of Home Alone
2. yeah
or he hit a three-pointer in the evening
blonde hair blue
I went to a Beyonce concert how did we
miss it started so uh Macaulay Culkin
spent a lot of time with Michael Jackson
speaking of people oh that's true the
one boy he did molest yeah exactly if
you just sent him back I'm like go tell
all your friends there's no molestation
you tell everybody same thing with you
Corey Haim and then when they're telling
me Oh yeah
that was the other one I thought it was
both of them no I think Corey Haim
judging by uh you know his grave site
added a little rough well I would bet
but uh Michael Jackson probably used the
call service for him and they
accidentally sent Feldman do you
remember in the the reality shows boys
oh we'll find them
sucks what do you remember the my two
Cory's reality show yeah yeah I used to
be silly but it was really just
basically impressed Diner the whole time
you know what happened to me you're like
this isn't fun at all not fun at all and
then Michael or uh Corey Hames or Corey
Feldman see I do it too yeah yeah is
still dressed like Michael Jackson
That's the creepiest part of him is he
dresses like like his attack he's a far
away from Tiger Beat who uh by the way
Rosenbaum has an entire Home Library yes
he does Tiger Beat magazine except you
can't open them anymore no he's a
collector he's like Bell and Beauty and
the Beast the library ladder just going
past Tiger Beat yeah in team beat
magazines and Lego instructions so uh
writtenhouse was a white supremacist
they actually even the former Vice
President of the United States to be
clear even made this claim passively by
including Kyle Rittenhouse in an ad
referring to White supremacists are you
willing tonight to condemn white
supremacists and militia groups and to
say that they need to stand down and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in Kenosha and as we've
seen in Portland yep there you go no
evidence for any of that by the way no
they tried to say it took a weapon
across state lines I believe there and I
said I would never use this but on a lot
of blogs including Young Turks they are
still saying they're repeating this live
which either means anyone who repeats
the LIE today that he took a firearm
illegally across state lines is either
lying to you most likely or too lazy to
do even the most basic level of research
yeah also very likely I mean yeah it
could be both could be both could be a
little bit it could be it's not a golden
dragon gun it's a hunting rifle right I
know it's just an AR-15 and it was an
assault style weapon a semi-automatic
even yeah like you know most every gun
the one that counts the bullet can we
use that description for like if they're
gonna say assault style yeah rifle can
we say assault style pedophile if
they've raped five miners you know I
think so that's one of those
hey that's assault style no no we call
him free to go yes yeah we call him free
to go yeah by the way it's a high
capacity magazine the refractory period
is just unreal you got to give them
credit words too and he has ear gauges
yeah I don't know if uh I don't know why
that makes it worse that's the other guy
oh was it my mistake sorry YouTube yeah
well it makes it harder for him to hit
you know I mean it's just more to miss
yeah it goes right through I feel like
thanks for making it wider yeah he's
like Pootie Tang yeah
[Applause]
no offense I wish we had the footage of
the guy who attacked him with the neck
razors but oh yeah that was lost to the
archives lost to the archives all right
are there any questions that you guys
have because I'm gonna go here too to
then go through the kind of key players
the prosecutor the judge but
I I just I so my I know this is silly to
ask but what are people hanging their
hat on like the aforementioned person
who we shall not mention again whose
network we mentioned
um loses his mind over this and calls
Kyle Rittenhouse a white supremacist and
a shooter and he just you know pissed
off that we can't see that he is
everything that they say he is it's like
what you have video of everything like
you see the entire thing yeah I feel
like a rational person on the left on
the right in the middle wherever you
happen to be would look at that and go
oh okay got it like that's a different
story than I've been told by the media I
didn't see that
how are they possibly trying to Rally
anybody to think Kyle Rittenhouse didn't
do anything
I mean that's the reality they need him
they need him to be the poster boy for
racial Division I mean what 100
distraction and this is the issue too
when you have these he's a kid he's
absolutely he's a kid but look at him
though look at the way that he carries
himself he's a kid yeah he's a kid and
he didn't he wasn't out there on a
murder street but even if he'd no he
wasn't out there in a murder spree
there's a very different I thought you
might say even if he was boys will be
boys come on come on white privileged
boys just make sure you're home after
dark yeah sorry I'm at curfew go out and
get some I should use that safety and by
safety I'm in this bring home pedophile
Pelt yes well try them with the natives
no I just when you look at them there's
there's certain intents you can just see
in a human being and there's obviously
even if any argument you have you can
you can look at the kid you can see how
he's carrying himself even if you don't
agree with what he did yeah he's a kid
he's 17. yeah there's there uh are there
six charges or seven charges against him
right now six charges there's first
degree Reckless homicide first degree
recklessly endangering safety first
degree intentional homicide attempted
first degree intentional homicide first
degree recklessly endangering safety
possession of a dangerous weapon by a
person under 18.
um so these are see that's too much that
shows me though that there's a lot more
going on here yeah you assume that any
lawyer could have gotten three of those
dropped if this wasn't absolutely here
and now yeah no I think you're
absolutely right and I just hope this
judge do we have that clip of the judge
saying come on now say nah what I don't
know what you're talking about about the
arsonist so this is uh you guys send it
in the control room here we'll be kind
of flying without a net uh one of the
prosecutors was saying you know we
cannot you know that mate did Mike did
Rosenbaum or not his clients but he was
Donald did they allegedly yell racial
slurs that has nothing to do with
attacking comedian house did they
allegedly commit arson that has nothing
and he goes the judge goes come on what
am I hearing now just a little bit of
arson what are you talking about
the quintessential Wisconsin accent yeah
yeah we're gonna break for a knockwurst
lunch yeah after that I don't know we're
gonna go down to anian's pretzels I like
a soft pretzel yeah
I like it she's there yeah I don't like
it oh don't you know it's real gouda
that's a little humorous Hey Garrett I
think it's K1 clip K1 clip K one not to
be confused with the synthetic marijuana
I like it soft like Rosenbaum looking at
a naked adult yeah you know but don't
get that guy around an 11 year old ah
cat couldn't scratch it oh I'd say
harder than a moose antler absolutely
and I know it sounds like we're being
you know a little uh distasteful in that
effect yeah that's all that's a fear
that's why I let him walk all right clip
is ready here's the clip I just love the
judge he's like he was this close to
saying don't bring that bull hokey in
here if there was any evidence in this
case that Mr Rosenbaum physically
attacked anyone else that night chased
anyone else that night assaulted anyone
else that night threatened anybody with
a weapon that night
we can talk about that but I don't hear
any evidence to that effect all we're
talking about is arson we're talking
about being loud and disorderly we're
talking about you know being I can't
believe some of the things you're seeing
is talking about is arson come on come
on
let's find a clip then he goes on he's
like well arson it was only a dumpster
well they were trying to push it into a
gas station yeah because my client
didn't ah you think people are gonna buy
that well it's okay if they're
protesting burning down gas stations up
on six but not near lasagna yeah well
just because there's just a little bit
of arson yeah a little bit of this yeah
a little bit arson yeah so what it's a
little bit I've never committed arson
but let's be honest in college we all
experimented yeah well
that's awesome matchbook into an
orphanage you know what I mean no no no
City it's a little just a little I've
burnt down some stuff but it wasn't on
purpose no no well no honestly I had a
bag of dog poop go very right I can
imagine well listen you don't take take
into account the methane no well it's
true we used to fill Kroger bags that
were like Yay big yeah and then we
soaked in gasoline well there's your
prop yeah oh there's your problem you're
stoking you're soaking poo and gasoline
oh my God the problem was we didn't wait
for him to answer the door to watch and
we just ran and it turned out they was
on vacation oh my gosh did I tell you
times have changed you know if people
say it's a little better arson they say
this guy just had sex with just a few
kids for me you know when I was growing
up you banged one kid you bathed him off
I mean if a neighbor wanted to take
photos of you you let them yeah let him
there was that one house you avoided but
they weren't pedophiles everywhere you
know it seems like Kyle Rittenhouse
couldn't uh throw a rack without hitting
there you know guy banging a kid he'll
watch a build a birdhouse yeah and then
he spills paints I know you take it off
he takes a Polaroid you get a sucker and
you called it a day by the way speaking
of bird houses the only thing I hate
more than than child rapists is a damn
squirrels they keep ruining my bird
feeders like to get out of here I want
to see the hummingbird I like my Stakes
well done I'm an
yeah you should see my wife she gets
that well done butterflied oh my god oh
I look into her I'm like and she's
that's funny too the Wisconsin moms oh
my gosh yeah he went in there after
those black fellas jerseys are taking
the oath but I think I have the full
clip okay so yeah let's fast forward to
the end of it where they start the guy
starts arguing like well the arsonery
was just at a the this is how thin their
arguments are it's a little bit of
arsonery a little bit arsenary come on
well they he wasn't he was it was a
dumpster they were pushing it towards
the gas station well you don't know that
my client pushed it towards the gas
station he was just there saying you
know push a dog go go go go all right
okay oh this video
I'm just waiting for the time after this
where you know I can uh play celebrate
good times command come on I'm about
ready to drop the confetti all right
let's see uh let's see uh you like a
deal I put a I put her on in my office
sometimes and I dance I think it's
veiled I don't really know what Rolling
in the Deep is but maybe Rosenbaum can
tell you in a kindergarten yeah he knows
a lot about that he knows shouldn't he's
just ankle deep in in kids asses that
guy's a pedophile
was I mean literally ankle deep yeah
what I wasn't
I mean that's not funny no no nothing
funny there's nothing funny if we're
talking about Justice
five-time child pedophile child molester
five-time molester anally raping
children death is horrible Justice would
never be that person no longer being
able to walk the earth and harm another
child in no way in whatsoever would that
be considered Karma to die absolutely
not absolutely not especially not
especially considering that he was not
reformed in any way and was still a
danger of course he should have been
able to he should you know what you know
yeah I guess now in 2021 I gotta say
that a pedophile who who bangs five kids
should be free to roam the Earth you
know like a Jack Pumpkin
at the pediatricians and he's ringing
the bell stand come on over here kids
come on well I didn't send him to prison
because when I saw that he had attacked
five children I thought to myself this
guy belongs in a nut house yeah he
belongs you know that whatever happened
to Good Old State asylums but then I
heard I thought I put him in The Nut
House you know yeah but then I heard
what they do to child rapists in prison
I said is that a fact and then I decided
to put him in general path
with with a sign
just pointing out who he is have we all
suspended now are discussed with
pedophiles how about serial pedophiles
who anally rape children no convicted
really we're gonna act now like Kyle
writtenhouse is the monster there's in
other words if you're gonna if you're
going to bring up something totally
irrelevant that Kyle Rittenhouse
shouldn't have been there in the first
place well you know what I don't know
why Rosenbaum was there it could have
been trolling for kids have no idea in
other words if you're going to bring
that as character assassination I don't
think it gets any worse than serial
child rapist convicted
changed my mind all right let's play the
rest of this clip and then we'll go to
the opening statements as they start
them
oh is it loading oh come on
Rittenhouse reloaded faster than that
yeah for crying out loud clear to jam
that guy was able to shoot one guy with
a skateboard clear a jam shoot a guy who
choked his girlfriend and you can't even
get uh you know a media he can't even
bring up a clip on CNN people probably
hate this voice but that is what he
sounds like you know what I don't care I
am who I am I'm gonna put extra chitter
in there yeah absolutely oh that is good
oh boy let's have two lunches and snack
today all right all right
oh my God they should be locked up with
the guy who bangs kids nope not gonna do
it nine
I say here's what we do we send this kid
away for life and let out Cosby can we
make it
makes perfect sense it's the world we're
living in that's not punishment tokenau
would be totally safer on that guy he's
not interested no
exactly I mean everyone is just
horrified at Cosby at least they were
adults well that's true at least drugged
adults really that's thank you Steven
Tyler
Cosby apologist that's right
you know
what you're saying what happened about
his arson come on
our arson to a dumpster your honor yes
well pushing towards the gas station
they claim yeah
this idea there's a there's a Zone where
it's it's okay that it's
on south of Sheridan Road because the
police are only going or uh 60th Street
because the police are only going to uh
uh that far south so I guess everybody
lives in this risk past that I don't
know what you're saying that's not what
I said your honor and Mr Rosenbaum did
not push the dumpster this is like yeah
you know just like what trying to play
claim you're playing that game or just a
tip to see how come on man uh that's
enough of that that's enough of that but
it's just so funny I love the lawyers
speak there a number of other people
were allegedly I'm sorry hold on uh
let's pull up the allegedly because oh
yeah so they actually are pushing it
towards the gas station pretty alleged
that's like saying Bill Cosby
accidentally hit the pill bottle and it
was just on a higher shelf and fell in
the drink 39 times well yeah it was a
little bit of rape allegedly come on
dear
they were adults and welcome
real world women when you're an adult no
that means that sometimes you're gonna
have to do things you don't want to do
that's right like me
badly me madly then you know I don't
have any more examples outside of me
there's a thing I got to cancel my Tour
on the counter nobody wants to see me
and I don't know why also I have to say
500 yards away
you know it would have been nice for him
to try to rehab His Image a little bit
Yeah front and center I just want to see
him just talk you know he's just talking
about just my little brother yeah my
little brother Russell you used to be
afraid to flush the toilet because it go
down any questions yeah how many women
did you raped
I don't know his hecklers wouldn't have
to Heckle they would just have to
present the newspaper to it they just
pulled up the pictures of victims yeah
he just thinks that they're in the
audience yeah it's just every seat is a
photo of so many rapes that the twist is
I would buy yes for this I would buy 40
seats in a row and just put pictures up
of all of them yeah like Trump with
Juanita Broderick with Hillary Clinton
yeah
that was well I was just trying to take
down black claws man Bill Cosby all
right let's see what they're saying
right now
reading the charges okay so they're
reading out the charges that he was
aware that his conduct created the
unreasonable and substantial risk of
death or great bodily harm
these circumstances of the defendant
um
where's Page seven the third element is
that the circumstances of the
defendant's conduct show utter disregard
for human life tried to find charge
number five
allegedly showed on her disregard for
human life
I consider these factors what the
defendant was doing why he was engaged
in that conduct how dangerous the
conduct was how obvious was the danger
whether the conduct showed any regard
for life and all other factions I think
I think him running with a fire
extinguisher and a medic kit shows that
he did have regard for life I think the
guy who destroyed the lives this is the
thing too that really bothers me about
all this look
it's the same thing with covid right
people say oh how much is my life worth
is it worth your business we've
separated life with just pulling a
trigger boom ending life which by the
way they tried to do to Kyle Rittenhouse
two but we've managed to in our modern
comfortable middle class lives and I
mean that for even poor Americans by the
way by any other
any other country in the world would be
considered upper middle class we've
separated loss of life
with loss of life with loss of the rest
of your life what do I mean by that
losing your livelihood with covet in a
business that you spent your entire life
building and through no fault of your
own losing being a child who was raped
by Rosenbaum
that destroys the rest of your life any
of you ever work with sexually abused
kids
I need to spend time with them because I
have particularly particularly special
needs kids
it destroys lives and we've separated
with oh how much is a life worth well he
didn't kill him
look
he raped the kids if you're going to say
the Cal ringhouse deserves to die
because he stayed after his shift as a
lifeguard in the town where he works and
businesses had been burned down if
you're going to make that argument that
he deserves to go to prison for life
then I'm going to make the argument that
you rape one kid
maybe a little leeway kid number two we
say maybe there's a pattern here four
five no
you lose you forfeit your right to live
well and when that kid kills himself or
ends up on drugs and dead early let me
say how is that not murder yeah because
once you do that to a child you are
killer I actually think raping a kid is
worse than most so do I yeah I really
think it's about as bad as it gets not
saying that he deserved to die for that
that night what I am saying is it was a
Justified shooting by Cal Rittenhouse
because this guy was running after him
assaulting him and of course in the
melee another gunshot was fired so the
shooting was justified but I also think
that we need to reset they want to talk
about the great reset where you think
everything is a human right they want to
talk about the great reset where we say
yep parents should lose custody of their
children if they refuse to put them on
puberty blockers how about the great
reset we want to find common ground
how about the Common Ground let's hit
the great reset where we all agree
five-time child rapist all right that's
a bad guy but instead people cannot even
acknowledge that they're a guy who
justifiably shot separate from they
can't even admit because he claimed to
be black lives matter that he's a bad
guy the guy in the Kaepernick afro there
and that clip cannot even bring himself
to tell the five-time child molester one
time at least on the record anally
raping a child repeatedly yelling the
n-word and the black guy in that crowd
says well he's not really a bad guy
because he has he's on the BLM side
there is no common ground and this is
why we are at we truly are on the verge
of a Civil War and this could be the
Catalyst dear God I hope not dear God I
hope the truth gets out but you want to
talk about media irresponsibility the
the only reason
that they ever stopped the lies is when
they get caught Nick Sandman right when
we found out Nathan Phillips we found
out they were being abused by black
Hebrew Israelites before the camera
footage came out
everyone thought that including
conservatives thought that kid deserved
to get his ass kicked Kyle Rittenhouse
the only reason the media would ever
stop is if enough people call them on
their lives and we're at the point where
they don't even do that they just pivot
yeah and say well Justice wasn't served
and so these people there's this civil
unrest and by the way maybe the guy was
just using black lives matter maybe the
serial pedophile and the and the the not
wife girlfriend Strangler they were
using black lives matter as an excuse to
go out and commit crimes kind of like
perverts who use the transgender
bathroom policy to sexually abuse women
at a certain point I don't care if
they're genuine or not you're giving
them the opening yeah well and something
I want to do I want to see if we can
bring this up maybe a little bit later
but yesterday morning I think it was 6
26 a.m I put this in show prep because
oh what a big man you are I know right
626 626 I I time coded it because CNN
referred to the bicep guy as uh the man
who was approaching Kyle Rittenhouse
approaching I kid you not yeah in their
story The Man approaching they used none
by the way they didn't use the footage
like it was a busboy would you like
sparkling or tap
return with that bread and hit you with
a skateboard yes exactly he was just
asking him if he wanted seconds right he
is the guy that is coming up and he's
their hero wearing the cap and he's the
guy that get shots on the bicep he's
approaching karenas these are the same
people that refer to Jacob Blake as
another black man shot by the way it's
what uh it's what what doordash says
when the order is coming to your house
yeah
like all people approaching it it's
literally yeah and they're away yeah
they're almost Freddy Krueger the
gentleman that was approaching the kid
OJ was approaching Nicole right yes
come on you know the Caps were just
approaching Rodney
yeah they were simply approaching him
with their batons many times and you
know sometimes I don't know if I'm a
captain that's right how do you approach
him without the steel toe boot I I don't
know the approaching him this is the
media and they're going here's the thing
once they lie it's an ego thing yeah
they can't say no we were wrong because
they they know they lied about it and
I'm not I try to not be in the business
of attributing motive but if someone
today in the mainstream media in any
media is saying that Kyle Rittenhouse
took a firearm across state lines I can
tell you beyond any shadow of a doubt
they are lying yeah they are lying if
they say that people were approaching
Kyle Rittenhouse or they were simply
attempting to unarm him because he was a
mass shooter they are lying if they say
Kyle Rittenhouse fired the first shot
they are lying if they say the police
arrested black lives matter protesters
but not the militiamen they are
lying none of it is true and it's all on
tape what if we didn't have the tape
that's when you got to worry about the
Civil War what if you don't have a take
what if what if you find yourself
in a city that maybe doesn't have the
most friendly gun laws but you still
have the right to carry but you know you
may forfeit your right to carry a
firearm if even you use it responsibly
and you happen to be mugged by someone
who has a darker shade of skin and you
protect yourself and there's no video
what do you think happens to you
that's the really scary thing here right
now is they're still trying to publicly
Lynch this kid yeah and there is ample
evidence that the kid is not guilty of
and again they move the goal post
they're now trying to say well okay
murder but okay maybe self-defense but
uh illegal firearm charge you're talking
about someone that's a slap on the wrist
yeah very very different why was he
across state lines ask CNN he worked
there he was a lifeguard he was 20
something minutes away they didn't tell
you that they just said he was across
state lines going into an area that he
didn't belong in and it's like wait a
minute we have video of him cleaning up
a building and rendering earlier they
don't believe in borders yeah exactly we
have him trying to put out a fire we
have him talking to people saying hey
I've got a medic kit right here I can
help you you've been injured I'm an EMT
where's America you were allowed to
drink so you are yeah that's true when
we're trying to stop drug cartels using
human mules and children across the Rio
Grande oh Elizabeth Pope we need to be
in we need to be a global account
economy there's no such thing as
countries borders only divide us he went
from Illinois to Wisconsin
yeah global economy is a great idea that
way the five people that are making this
happen stop yawning Kyle yeah don't yawn
Kyle put your hand up I know you're
tired yeah by the way I really do feel
bad for Kyle but he does have a face
like a piglet
he well he does he looks like he bought
one of those shirt and tie uh
collections at Marshalls yes exactly yes
with the yeah that you wear at your
graduation yeah yeah it looks like you
should be um like he like the first time
you fingered a girl sorry I'm sorry
there you go he looks like he should be
singing we're not afraid of the big bed
sorry Everyone
by the way I I don't want to uh but come
on come on I'm saying the kid has a baby
face that kid doesn't even shave that's
what I mean
this is just so stupid
race I have his lawyer tell him that had
nothing to do with race careful
otherwise the judge is going to come
after you cow now listen would you step
for God's sake yeah in my courtroom am I
that boring do I have to bring out more
uh more more more Scattergories well
it's not even he didn't seem to be born
on August 20th
getting there what what are you saying
oh oh my mirroring thing well the reason
is because I'm not actually using it I
have the show map printed out okay uh go
ahead yawning isn't necessary it's not
like Kyle's boredness I used to yawn in
the weight room and my coach would get
pissed at me it's like no my body needs
oxygen like are you on every time you
talk I need to get some well hey hey
how's it going I'm trying to make a
laugh I yawn every time I go out for
drinks with Brian stelter you're gonna
come back look at me Dave I'm looking at
you look at me I'm looking this better
be good I can't really see you that hurt
I'm sorry oh my gosh what a nandy Hamby
over here I'm sorry someone please light
a dumpster on fire and throw it in his
eye
I'm sorry Gerald I thought I wanted to
treat you like a five-year-old look me
in the eye no look me in the eye if you
if we did compare sizes you could treat
me like a five-year-old I'm trying to
see what should we go through the uh I
have a bunch of notes Here don't they're
probably gonna start opening statements
like any second now they're just going
through the final have they put on their
powdered wigs well no not yet that's a
silly country upstairs
one uh one thing that we have that
should be coming up in the trail Kyle's
being charged with recklessly
endangering the life of the daily color
videographer Richie McGinnis this was
the guy who interviewed him about the
medic kit said that guy is going to be
how is he Reckless what I don't know
yeah did he get shot I'm sorry what he
he was the guy that uh looks like took
off his shirt to hell oh yeah how did he
recklessly endanger his life I'm curious
he just wanted to take off his shirt
he's like let me well look let's go
through let's go through the the counter
claim that they're making uh that uh the
attacks from Cal Rittenhouse run
provoked no that's absolutely not sure
you just saw it on the videotape these
attacks were absolutely self-defense uh
that the people Rittenhouse shot were
completely innocent well not only are we
talking about long criminal records of
strangling women raping children we were
talking about them committing crimes
that very night felonies on camera
um here's another uh claim of course
we'll say there was no reason for Cal
Rittenhouse to be there in the first
place this is kind of where they're
starting to get pretty thin but that's
these are the only arguments that they
have left
because of videotape
um
okay first off he works there
he works there and driving from Illinois
to his place of work is not very far and
there were businesses asking for help
now they will bring up the fact they'll
say well actually the business that he
claimed he was protecting said he didn't
want cowardness to protect him yeah and
the guy also fled the state immediately
okay he's like no no we didn't need
anyone to protect us bye and then you
reach and there's just a there's just a
dust-shaped cloud of where that guy used
to be is
that he illegally possessed a firearm
this is another claim that they'll make
not true that he illegally crossed state
lines with a firearm of course not true
now
that he was a member of the militia
white supremacist absolutely not true
there's been no evidence of that even
the prosecution hasn't even submitted
any evidence of that yeah now the one
the one charge and I'll give this to you
the one charge that they may be able to
make stick
is the gun whether it was legal right
now let me read to you why uh from
wisconsin.gov this section applies only
to a person under 18 years of age who
possesses or is armed with a rifular
shotgun if the person is in violation of
s 941.28 or is not in compliance this
section applies only to an adult who
transfers a firearm to a person under 18
years of age if the person under 18
years of age is not in compliance with
SS
29.304 so this is something people need
to understand people who hunt there are
always exceptions with long guns for
hunting and it's very very common in
Midwestern states a lot of the times
people don't understand when you look at
gun laws you say it doesn't make sense
or you look at some knife laws that
don't necessarily make sense some knife
laws I believe in Michigan now you can
open carry knives Beyond a certain size
because Hunters were carrying them when
they were dressing deer oh Texas you can
carry a sword really yeah open carry wow
and some nerds rejoiced oh yeah we were
just like machete we were excited like
you know yeah don't believe in a
mechanical advantage of a firearm I
think my weapon of choice as the weakest
man in only the technical sense of the
word is a sword that requires skill and
force
hey by the way McGinnis the guy that
they're charging him with uh like
recklessly endangering yeah so when when
he is called to the witness stand he
should probably come to Cal's defense
because he's been saying that he thinks
he's very innocent he believed he was
there to help he just didn't realize how
dangerous the situation was right sounds
like he's on his side so that's good but
they're still charging they're charging
it's like well that's the thing is and
you just say reckless endangerment
because he had a firearm that's the
thing the second you discharge a firearm
there are all these criminal
consequences I understand that but so
basically what they're trying to do
right now is criminalize you standing
out in front of a building wearing
militia gear right and holding a weapon
yeah point it down at the ground t-shirt
them shorts yeah exactly that's what
they want to criminalize right now I
don't want to be facts they shouldn't
have been there oh really on an average
day sure
you know if you're just standing outside
it's unbelievable it might be a little a
little odd if the city's on fire you're
kind of like I get it yeah yeah kind of
understandable that's kind of
understandable I almost would be
surprised not seeing that by the way are
we asking the same questions I know you
asked it kind of you know joking yes
the same questions of the people that
were there why did you have a gun bicep
guy like why why were you packing that
night yeah yeah I saw his answer in the
New York Times video because it's my
right oh oh really so it's you're right
but it's not Kyle rittenhouse's right to
protect himself when you're trying to
shoot him with said gun right yeah well
that's what I'm gonna say he also
believes it's his right to shoot a guy
after he's been you know rattled by a
skateboard yeah well chase down the
street he is anti-skater I will say this
you have the right to shoot anyone you
should who tries to knock you
unconscious with a skateboard hey inches
away how many people get killed all the
time from blunt objects it's very common
not only can the person kill you with a
skateboard person could hit you you
could go unconscious hit your head in
the concrete in other words the second
you put someone in a situation where
they might lose their life and they have
to act to defend it you forfeit your
right to live I'm not saying that you
deserve the death penalty big difference
if you go when you hit someone in the
face with a skateboard what I am saying
is in that moment in time that little
flash moment in time when you are about
to hit a guy with a skateboard you've
forfeited your right to live because
that person may have to decide you or
him if you mug somebody and you hold
them at gunpoint and they kill you guess
what fair game why this person doesn't
know if you're going to ask them to get
on their knees and kill them this person
person doesn't know your intent this
person doesn't know if you're sober or
on drugs you have forfeited your right
to live and I would certainly argue that
when you yell get his ass get his ass
shoot me inward shoot me inward
throughout the night whip your at
the guy and then have your buddy fire a
gun in the air and then uh this is of
course Rosenbaum I would argue he
forfeited his life to live after raping
his third child
but then then later you forfeit your
right to live yeah hit him with a
skateboard you forfeit your right to
live when you're bringing a handgun up
trying to shoot him on the ground all
these are consequences to actions I do
not believe that Kyle Rittenhouse
forfeited his right to live just because
he happened to be in one ZIP code right
you guys let me know comment below what
you think we'll be taking your chat on
Blaze uh later on on mug club and of
course we'll be doing the Cal
Rittenhouse challenge where we have Nerf
guns we'll reenact this scenario to see
if anyone can make that superb shot if
you look at Kyle Rittenhouse I think
personally and this is obviously
speculation I believe that's the term
but if you look at Kyle uh Rittenhouse
it was a group of people who saw
somebody who they thought was weak and
wouldn't have actually used their weapon
and that's why they charged at him in
the first place into their surprise
somebody's missing his bicep and uh
bicep biceps
bicep no I heard myself that's what
Chuck Norris says on the Total Gym
commercials like now I'm working my
biceps well yeah except it's like oh
I'll go put on another hair hat hey you
know what you know who I trust no one
about muscles Chuck Norris technically
it's biceps
yeah token down just put you in
your place you were off by one letter
yeah well I don't know words I think
we've established that on this show all
right let's see what this judge is
saying I want to hear if he's saying nah
come on I don't want to hear you saying
about dumpsters yeah they're talking
about McGinnis okay you're guilty the
evidence must satisfy you beyond a
reasonable doubt that the defendant is
guilty which it won't if you can
reconcile the evidence upon any
reasonable hypothesis consistent with
the innocence of the defendant then you
must do so and find him not guilty which
is what you should do the term
Reasonable Doubt means a doubt based
upon reason and common sense it is a
doubt for which your reason can be given
arising from Affair and rational
consideration of the evidence or want of
evidence it means such as
Prudence to pause or hesitate when
called upon to act in the most important
Affairs of Life Kyle's making money
would you stop that young man that's
contagious I I'd have a good mind to let
you walk but if you weren't acting like
such a horse's ass
igning in my courtroom guilty of yawning
is that your friend in the wood chipper
that's what they should call him over
there back at the Schoolhouse as they
should call him Kyle the girl
writtenhouse yeah Kyle boring house yes
you're sitting there yawning no no I'm
boring listen I'll tell you every party
I go to uh yeah on the cut up you're
getting worked up again so right before
that with regards to the Reckless ending
for McGinnis the judge was saying that
if Kyle was acting within reason in
defending himself from Rosenbaum then he
would not have been in violation in
regards to endangering McGinnis yeah
well that makes sense chasing you down
mouse was underage and he's being chased
by a pedophile for crying out loud
that's not reasonable suspicion hey hey
why were you running from that guy where
are you right hey hey everybody Kyle
where are you running from him because
you know that guy I don't know if you're
another funny five kids were you
running because you were afraid he was
gonna try and plow your you in the ass
were you number six because you're 17
but you got passed you could pass for a
12 to 14. yeah he may not have known but
when you see that guy yelling the n-word
at a gas station nobody doing anything
about it pretty sure people thought he
was crazy yeah I'm pretty sure people
have an intimidating presence he was
released that day yeah for being crazy
right but seriously hey Reasonable
Suspicion like I would want to go at
your honor uh I thought he was trying to
have sex with me
because he has sex with children and I'm
17 but I look very young all right now
all right opening statements let's hear
opportunity to make an opening statement
now or if he prefers he is entitled to
reserve his openings
okay about about the fires in a little
bit of arsenary Iowa or past there yeah
a little bit of arson all right there
you know you and I settled that over a
pack of strolls we talked about that
right yes we did you may proceed man
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen go ahead full Hawk
the evidence in this case will show
could uh Robert Downey Jr is Iron Man
please so if you're in our community of
Kenosha still in costume oh I want to
hear it's all Written House who was 17
years old at the time
had armed himself with an AR-15 style
semi-automatic rifle loaded with 30
rounds magazine and using that rifle he
shot and killed Joseph Rosenbaum an
unarmed man
by the shot that killed Mr Rosenbaum was
a shot to the back
[Music]
this occurred after the defendant chased
down
Mr Rosenbaum
and confronted him
while wielding that AR-15 did he just
say he chased down Rosenbaum yeah the
evidence
chased him down of the dead body of
Joseph Rosenbaum without stopping to
offer any Aid whatsoever yes he did
that's a lot he did
word spreads from the crowd on the
street
that there is an active shooter running
through the area
and the citizens there attempt to stop
him by the way don't you love how
everything he's discussing is not on
tape right yeah the word spread oh
really hits him with a chain by the way
oh yeah because no one's ever been hurt
by a chain
eventually
falls to the ground
I thought he was Ghost Rider an
individual who is the subject of count
number two the unknown individual
runs in at that point and attempts to
kick the defendant in the face while the
Defenders on the ground this unknown
individual is unarmed
the defendant in response points his
AR-15 directly at this individual as
this individual is literally flying over
his body and discharges that gun twice
luckily that individual is not hit
but clearly if he had been hit
the wound would have been severe how
does someone fly over your body he's
counting as he goes to sleep I
mean
holding a skateboard holding comes in
and reaches for the defendants no no no
we bring up those still images of him of
him no stomping his head and hitting him
in the head with a skateboard okay with
those images I can't sorry guys I don't
have it on the show man skipped over a
little important part there
oh let's hear it again
and the gun is slung oh yeah so it is
essentially attached to him then reaches
cuber's efforts by the way the
prosecution is kind of that they have
FBI Drone footage
and in that struggle the gun winds up
pointed directly at Mr Huber's chest
the defendant pulls the trigger one time
and discharges around into Mr Huber's
chest
killing him instantly
a final individual by the name of Gage
Grossman see what he says here has
followed this Chase on foot and has
approached the defendant at this time
approached this gross kreitz is holding
his cell phone that he'd been using to
record the night really for a live
stream on Facebook what about the other
one hand
and a Glock semi-automatic pistol in the
other hand
he runs up to the defendant
the defendant turns towards him with the
AR-15 Mr gross quartz raises his hand
the defendant then turns his rifle over
begins to examine it for a second Mr
gross kreutz takes this opportunity and
you will see in the photos and the
videos
that he blades his body with his left
hand reaching towards the defendant his
right arm is pulled back this is the gut
one with the gun in his hand
and as he's reaching for the defendant
the defendant turns the AR-15 and
discharges here's what
I do if I'm doing the detective novel
thing look hold on a second hold on a
second here's what he just said bring up
that picture by the way bring up that
picture of him being shot in the bicep
yeah he says here's Kyle Rittenhouse
okay so look at me guys your Cal
Rittenhouse yeah okay so let's bring the
camera back on me
he says he reaches blades his hand to
reach for the gun and retracts his arm
here okay so look from the side coward
now we've seen the angle is off to his
left diagonal hey can you shoot my left
bicep
how much do I have to angle
for you to be able to shoot me here
if he's bladed trying to just reach for
the gun gently did you hear that
argument unbelievable there's no
possible way so you're Cal Rittenhouse
okay we know the angle was about here
right the angle was about here the guy
was a little bit off maybe at what would
you call it
uh four o'clock
to Kyle Rittenhouse yeah the cow
writtenhouse I don't know yeah anyway
this is somewhere around there yeah look
right so in other words he's on the only
way he could shoot him on that side is
if the arm which you see in the picture
is extending to shoot that opening
statement is he was here with his arm
bladed this arm retracted with his gun
why the implications that he didn't plan
on doing any damage with his gun sure
how can you look at this yeah be shot in
the bicep
yeah done come on
come on business there car Source one of
their locations on Sheridan and other
properties around town that were damaged
burned fortunately in the entire
sequence of events
this was all property damage
yeah what if someone did
cleared the property to make sure no one
was in there and by the way do you think
they cared
well how would you like it if everything
you've ever worked for is burnt and let
out of fire and your entire car lot that
your entire life this is the new
comfortable life right you've never
you've never run a business you've never
worked a job you're Perpetual you're
professionally unemployed and said to
you it's well it's just stuff guess what
wars were fought over far far less look
at the Native Americans they were
scalping over trees
the American Revolution started because
of a two because of a two cent tax on on
a breakfast drink and this is before Red
Bull you have an idea how out of their
mind they would have been
that's a hell of a surge commercial my
point is they separate from their cozy
lives those are just things did they
clear it make sure that they're only
things because a lot of people died over
these riots yeah
but when you have nothing or and you
have no pride of ownership and you don't
work for anything nothing matters no
absolutely true all right so let's keep
going all of those reactions were
entirely understandable and reasonable
and no one here is going to tell you
otherwise
as long as those are what you're left
doing that is stressful
for real yeah
but out of the hundreds of people
that came to Kenosha during that week
the hundreds of people that were out on
the streets that week the evidence will
show
that the only person who killed anyone
was the defendant were they all chased
yeah it'd be like saying the evidence
shows let's say nine people okay let's
say 19 people
invade your home Panic Room Jody Foster
only don't have the budget for that kind
of a closet they all come into your room
19 people and they're dead set on raping
your wife and killing you how do you
know because they say
I'm a rapist
I'm gonna rape your wife and I'm gonna
kill you and your son comes upstairs and
you get a beat on him and you grab your
semi-automatic shotgun and he grabs his
AR-15 and boom boom boom boom boom all
19 are stopped and killed would it be do
you think it would be fair do you think
it would be an accurate depiction of the
situation for a lawyer to say however
despite the 23 people being there four
people in your family 19 home Invaders
the only people who were shot
were my 19 clients you mean when they
had an erection in a butcher's knife
yeah exactly
out of the millions of people at the
Capitol only one person killed someone
it may be a fact that my clients had
Chinese rings on and they had they
had kitchen knives however
they left without their lives listen is
it like a Chinese finger trap I have no
idea by American that's all I'm saying I
caught all right let's go Kyle
Rittenhouse I'll tell you exactly who it
looks like he looks like that guy from
Dark Knight who's a English actor who's
on a plane with Bane he's like you know
they can take it you're a big guy find
that guy's name there in the controlling
you'll see that's exactly who this guy
looks like from our community also he's
an it helps solve a murder
that's a good actor we're not asking you
of this guy to solve a mystery in this
case no but self-defense you're right in
most homicide cases the elements that I
need to prove might be a little
challenging but here there's no doubt
there will be no dispute in this record
that the defendant had that gun that
night
shot eight bullets four of them hit
Joseph Rosenbaum two of them at an
unknown individual one into Anthony
Huber's chest and one into gauge gross
quartz's arm that will not be right he
just said no there will be no Mysteries
and then said it went to one unknown
individual
the magical individual of mystery who
disappeared what is a Sleepy Hollow you
just said no Mysteries
yeah he looks like him hold on real
quick because he's talking about his
defense use deadly force
there is a privilege under our lost he
used deadly force but it's a very
limited privilege
that privilege according to the law
indicates that the defendant
can only use deadly force if he
reasonably believed
that the force was necessary to prevent
imminent death like a gun Point bodily
harm to himself I don't know you ever
been hitting ahead with a skateboard
truck yeah in determining whether or not
those beliefs were reasonable
the standard is what a person of
ordinary intelligence and prudence would
have believed in the defendant's
position
under the circumstances that existed at
the time is this prosecutors
must be determined from the standards
at the time of his acts and not with the
benefit of hindsight
it's worse at the time I would have shot
more people probably because I didn't
have the discipline here everyone would
have yeah apply that standard of
reasonableness to the defendant's
behavior and make a determination
as to whether or not his use of deadly
force it looks reasonable was it
reasonable yes for the defendant to
believe that the force was necessary to
prevent imminent death or great bodily
harm to himself well it did say they
were going to kill him so I was Kyle
Rittenhouse I'd be nodding right now and
they were crying yeah as well so yeah I
would say yes uh your honor they told me
they were going to kill me and then they
tried to kill me uh rest my case
well how about lunch I hear Auntie
Anne's has a two for one yep that was a
quick one I don't hate Bob Evans it's
not my favorite but I like it oh it's
okay yeah you know but the Early Bird
yeah let me tell you what that dude
yeah I have a Mexican omelette it's very
delightful together in the months
leading up to August 25th 2020. in fact
on May 1st of 2020 Dominic black bought
the AR-15 for the defendant that
occurred up in Ladysmith Wisconsin
Dominic black used money that was given
to him by the defendant to go to an Ace
Hardware up in Ladysmith and buy the gun
in Dominic's Black's name now you might
ask
why was it necessary for Dominic black
to do that why couldn't the defendant do
that
because the defendant was 17.
and Dominic black it was Raz Simone and
Chaz ever charged when he was handing
out AR-15s to underage kids he didn't
know no no he was buying those with the
money he got from the government as a
grant yeah in fact a straw purchase on
behalf of Dominic black on behalf of the
defendant
after the gun is purchased in Ladysmith
Dominic black and the defendant spent a
little time up there at Dominic Black's
family's hunting property and they fired
both that AR-15 and one that Dominic
black already had and the two of them
are practicing using their AR-15s good
at a shooting range that they have in
that property sounds responsible okay
I'll tell you some more about that
then they agreed that that gun would not
go home with the defendant to his home
in Antioch Illinois
it would stay here in Kenosha at the
residence of Dominic Black's State
observance of the law it's making the
case and in fact after the two of them
returned from ladies
Johnson right now everyone is a producer
at CNN or leftist YouTube channel is
going like oh
this isn't the defense no it's not the
defense no no apparently this is not
this is the prosecutor yeah yeah no I'm
as confused as you are my friend yeah
what was going on in Kenosha so it was
responsible to responsibly use it and it
was left where it was supposed to be
safe listen listen then they decide they
want to come back later that night it's
like oh they come down they clean up
some graffiti and stuff you know but
that's not that's not what they're doing
it's located at 59th and Sheridan what
were uh what were the other guys doing I
was like ripping about yesterday car
Source actually has three locations very
close in this downtown area let's think
about this for this for a second Kyle
Rittenhouse was cleaning up a grade
school the guy he shot wouldn't be
allowed within 100 yards of one well
that's why actually that guy was
breaking the law by even being there
yeah all right seriously you're right
cars in the parking lot that were set
fire and completely burned out all of
them the building itself was damaged as
well burned down
right across the street from there is
another car Source location that also
sold used cars and some of those cars
had been damaged on the night of Monday
August 24th because black lives matter
active as an answer they're really
sticking it to the rich by going after a
used car lots of Kenosha yeah that's
where Madoff hides his uh offshore funds
59th Street location that night
and there's some discussion about that
in the afternoon Mr Black and the
defendant go out to jelinski's out on
Highway 31 Green Bay Road and they
acquire straps so that they can sling
those guns around themselves when they
come back to the downtown area that
night and also responsibly later
they meet up with some other folks that
are interested in protecting car Source
originally they start out at 63rd Street
Car source which is the third and final
car Source location but then they agree
we're going to go to the 59th Street
59th and Sheridan location and protect
that location to make sure no one
damages double check is safe No One
damages the property and I want to be
clear
there's nothing wrong with that what is
it protecting that property this is the
prosecution he's going to keep making
the case for the defense and then uh
just stop yeah many people here in
Kenosha did he's like what I give up and
there's a group of people including the
defendant and dominant clack that take
up positions what I'm saying is I quit
your honor he thought this was a live
read for a Warby Parker commercial so I
picked up the wrong notes this job is
difficult
you know it's not for me your honor he
took up a position on the roof he had
Bundy was a better lawyer
other folks were close to where
potential
in The Dark Knight Rises he looks more
like this guy
mayor Quimby yeah
[Music]
all right people here and see videos of
sequence of events going on around
Kenosha that night I bet they will yeah
the evening begins with large-scale
protests large-scale uh writing no other
way to put it rioting
what is going on that's three there's no
other way to put it Rosenbaum
[Laughter]
yeah you know but is that a reason for
him to lose his life I I would I would
see this guy doing this your honor I uh
I have the defenses notes can I go
change I think I'm on the wrong team
here your honor of the defense would
like to cross-examine the prosecution I
gotta be honest I live in that
neighborhood and I just wanted to shake
this man's hand this guy says it's an
honor this guy's the assistant D.A wow
well where's the where's First Street
when you need it yeah
this is a paper authentication I'm
always getting off well there goes uh
that charge and uh yeah that charge too
that that one's gone uh
boy this is gonna keep going really
putting it on the jury this is difficult
the jury's looking for the head there's
one black guy in the jury like come on
man give me a reason come on come on
you're killing me
the kid goes to that school what's the
name of his friend
name was was he black
okay so the guy on the n-word was was
white oh
go
I gotta go
I can't believe I didn't get out of this
I told the judge everybody you know what
judge I don't think I should be here
because uh I'm gonna kill that
right there so I believe I
will be excused I haven't told the judge
I hated black people just let me off
don't just told him that I don't know
what else I gotta say uh Asians make me
uncomfortable smell weird uh I don't
know uh I hate Five Below but you have
just ruined the last 20 years of
barbecues for me Mr lawyer all right
let's see what this is the worst
prosecution
Prosecuting opening statement I've ever
gotta have a hand turn or something yeah
let's see Ventures out into it he's
going to bring out the prestige
[Music]
well because if it's not the prestige
right now it's just the tiger eating
Siegfried yeah
but the defendant is stationed at is no
longer in danger
[Music]
there's no one there who's attempting to
damage the property there's no one there
who's going to do anything to harm
anyone there
yeah because he's there the situation
has moved out that's because they tried
to burn down a gas station and if not
for him and his fire extinguisher there
would have probably been successful but
the fact that you mean guards make it
less likely for people to penetrate the
property and cause damage
do you have any idea the damage that's
setting fire to a gas station would do
oh my gosh like none of those people
rise it's like you'd probably all be
dead yeah all of you yeah into the crowd
they crossed the police line at 60th and
Sheridan
and they walk amongst this group of
hostile protesters
at some point they both wind up at a gas
station wow why didn't they say mostly
people called ultimately yeah and you'll
see some video of the scene there it is
a scene again of groups of people that
are clashing with one another verbally
there's some shoving going on physical
and in the midst of this is Joseph
Rosenbaum
and you will hear some testimony about
Mr Rosenbaum and his activities that
night enough we'll hear his own work Mr
Rosenbaum had been discharged from the
hospital that very day and had come back
to his home of Kenosha what is it your
honor he had climbed down a rope of bed
sheets lucky he was getting out for a
heart attack talk about why he's gonna
go through his rap sheets they're gonna
bring out his doctor right at the psych
ward he's coming up like I looked into
rosenbaum's eyes yeah and saw pure evil
yeah it's just dumb
didn't he just open the door your honor
he said he was released from the
hospital why was he in the hospital yeah
that's a good point possible to bring
that in yeah you should yeah you should
yeah you should be able to he introduced
it because he said Donald Pleasence
pointed Rosenbaum touch another kid
again and your honor on page four penis
oh somebody wrote on oh no somebody I
don't even know why I said it it's
really just scribbled on your picture
but it's Hooked on Phonics what kind of
Hospital you know that that's not really
important he got out that day the
defense is over there giggling every
time he reads one of the handwritten
notes they put in wait was was your
former client uh admitted to child
rapist Presbyterian
I don't know it was kid Banger Lutheran
oh I'm sorry right down the street
talking about Lennox this guy's
definitely cheated off the person next
to him
to kill and do a better job than this
he set it free
yeah
I know the lawyers just writing down
point out what kind of Hospital
I know what you're thinking black people
are gross black people are inferior that
they commit rape they commit murder
I rest my case
that boom rad oh he's something else big
old oak tree it's time all right
sorry let's go back to the prosecution
to listen listen to him yeah the
defendant attempts to he comes up to the
police line
history
and again they won't let him directly
through the line right now I believe the
evidence will show that he could have
easily gone a block in either direction
if he really wanted to go back but he
turns away from the police line returns
to the ultimate gas station
and a few minutes later we see him on
the video of a man by the name of Corey
Elijah who will testify very shortly
here in this trial
Mr Corey Elijah was one of these people
out on the streets who was Facebook live
streaming the events of that night and
he catches the defendant passing right
in front of him with a fire extinguisher
what is this guy a gun still slung
around it's a fire extinguisher no he's
leading he's leaning over right now he
stole my opening statement where is he
going with this fireworks
this is what I wrote he looks like he's
he's looking at this prosecutor right
now like the Miami Heat would be when
they're down
when they are when they are down a point
or sorry they're up one point and Shaq
is up in the Life basically
basically the defense is using the
tactic from the last scene in Eight Mile
bear tell them something they don't know
about me uh it's like okay listen listen
I want to see what he says about this
but he is though by Joseph Rosenbaum who
at this point is taking this shirt off
he's got shorts on and he's taking this
shirt and kind of wrapped it around his
head he's going through ourselves
like a towel head if you want her if he
was seven Rosenbaum would have loved
is behind him
at some distance
as they get down to the 6200 into the
6300 block of Sheridan Road that block
on the west side of Sheridan has a house
right at the corner of 62nd and Sheridan
and then
Rosenbaum raised their kids it's abandon
him you will hear testimony from someone
from the FBI if it was up in a plane
that night taking video okay and we will
show you the video
this is at night time so regular cameras
especially from an airplane aren't going
to be able to see everything so the
infrared helps us to see in the dark
just sees a throbbing erection from
Rosenbaum as he passes by the it's the
Jamboree thing in the picture
he's running by a jamboree and you see
whoa
would help conceal some of that heat but
when you don't have your shirt on that
heat radiates and the infrared picks it
up more clearly so he's very easy to see
in the video as a white dot yeah it's a
white trash running towards the 63rd car
source
and behind him running in the same
direction following him is the defendant
as they get to the 63rd Street Car
Source there are some cars on the North
side he's trying to say that right now
was running asking him before we see him
in that video on the other side of those
cars and turn no no I know exactly was
running past him
now obviously in the video in an
infrared video from a plane overhead we
don't know exactly what was going on at
that very moment I don't know what words
were said so let's not believe the up
close footage whatever that
confrontation from multiple angles let's
believe the Predator cam from the
all-reliable FBI plane not even a
chopper by the way so keep in mind it's
very hard to get that kind of footage uh
with most standard planes that the FBI
would be driving over riding over
Kenosha piloting whatever who cares yeah
here we go at some point during that
foot pursuit the defendant turns around
points the gun at Mr Rosenbaum why would
he turn around if he was chasing
Rosenbaum remember he has got no shirt
on
he's got his hands up in the air almost
like what are you gonna do
real
you're good what would you say that
pointing at Mr Rosenbaum continues to
run
almost a challenge
there is a gunshot aggressively oh
there's a gunshot
we have identified by the name of Joshua
zaminsky this is an individual who's
walking on the sidewalk probably 30 feet
away firing the defendants
Mr zaminski for reasons only he can
explain decided to take his handgun and
fire it one time in the air
as I said this is in a different
direction and many 30 feet away 30 feet
guns are loud continues to pursue the
defendant and we will have detective
Martin Howard testify that he's timed
the gap between Mr zaminski's shot
and the eventual gunshots is about 2.5
or 2.6 seconds
Five Wounds total from four bullets we
have a Magic Bullet Dr Kelly will
testify that the first two they went
here turned in the air Mr Rosenbaum back
to his lower back and to the left we're
not sure which order they were in but
one was to his right pelvis fracturing
his pelvis there's irony and one was to
his left lower thigh
yeah God did that
Dr Kelly will testify that these wounds
caused to control everything
God is in control predestination see
video of his body where it is found he
lands on his face face down on the
ground
as he is following falling the defender
fires two more shots
one of them hits the defendant in the
back or I'm sorry Mr Rosenbaum in the
back and that is the shot that kills Mr
Rosenbaum according to Dr Kelly
which is sad you will hear testimony
from someone by the name of Richie
McGinnis
Richie McGinnis in Kenosha Rosenbaum
kimowitzki right written house shortly
before these shootings he encounters the
defendant in 59th Street and interviews
him he talks to the defendant
and then follows the defendant down
shared in Rome and is right behind the
defendant as these shootings are occur
in fact he is in the car Source lot he
is behind Mr Rosenbaum when Mr Rosenbaum
is shot
Mr McGinnis will testify that one of
those rounds came close to him which is
this a Daily Caller guy that Mr McGinnis
was uh recklessly
um
harmed or placed him wait you're calling
the witness who supports calories
I'm wondering what that detective he's
talking about the detective is going to
show me like uh oh you're the
prosecution uh
kids are good shots yeah you know did
you get hit by the bullet well well no
no no he had amazing trigger disability
no Jesus you're cutting away because
they're doing too much damage she
doesn't know what to do well the
statement still going on are they done I
I it seemed like the statement was still
going on back up
they're good now
to freighter itself formerly known as
Kenosha Memorial Hospital kmh which
happens to be right across the street
these folks load him into a hospital SUV
that's there in the back of it and it
races off towards the emergency room to
try and save Mr rosenbaum's life
that's what Mr McGinnis does
the defendant after shooting Mr
Rosenbaum
gets on his phone calls Dominic black
and says I just shot somebody and starts
running away wait you forgot something
he circled back to check on him we
already showed the video
entire evening held himself out as an
EMT as a medic that he's carrying a
medical bag with him he wants to his
body
and yet in this time of Mr Rosenbaum
there on the ground
injured
nope their feet cut out again
is this the only place showing at court
TV yeah I'm sure it's all over yeah
that's right I think it's the courts I
don't think system is going to have this
well
I think they had said that all the other
channels that we'll be playing this are
using Court TV's feed yeah okay and
they're going to cut in well I think
it'd be more interesting to watch it on
CNN anyway because we might get some of
their uh commentary earlier they weren't
I hope they cut back to CNN and Don
Lemon just is going uh
this
what is this oh my gosh this is a CNN
commercial yeah really okay let's go
back to court TV I'm a sheepdog woman
oh my gosh morning I love how I hope
that I really hope Kyle's lawyer just
gets up and goes
everything that guy said no no I want
him to do that but I want to be like you
know what most of what he said was true
yeah most of what he said he was pretty
good you're right there was physical
confrontations by these guys there was
rioting going on Kyle was there to help
out and he did clean up stuff the other
day earlier in the day he did come back
to help defend some businesses which he
did and it was successful they made a
great case he did also render Aid and
put his life the greatest sin that he
just accused Cal Rittenhouse of
committing is not using his medic kit to
save the guy who was chasing him while
people were yelling get his ass get his
ass he just shot somebody get him yeah
in other words like that's the worst he
can come up with by the way there was
not just one guy chasing after him
Rosenbloom went no there were several
people in the video chasing some of them
with Pikes the mystery guy as uh the
prosecutor called him mystery man
mystery man for the purposes of this
Trail let's call him a pedophile number
two there are no questions to be asked
here we know everything except for that
mystery man we haven't been able to find
him and what's that guy's name uh I
don't know oh I haven't found him yet
yeah I gotta be honest I just made more
of a shadowy figure really yeah red eyes
yeah I was actually gonna take the stand
and ask myself questions yeah you know I
actually need to get to the bottom of it
are the cameras still looking no Like
Bugs Bunny is a lawyer yeah yeah I don't
know why I'm here yeah later on I might
uh you know get a few uh get a few Pabst
and he might uh turn into a girl bunny
yeah that Jessica Rabbit Dame huh like
that FBI director of Hoover with no
she's not a book cam all right let's go
back including many different videos
many different uh photos of the scene
that night we are going to use that
television to show you these things so
that you can see them yourself okay I
know many of you alluded to the fact
yesterday that you've watched or read
things about this
you will get the full story here in the
courtroom self-defense we'll see some
things that have not been made public
yet good job fairly okay we intended to
be doing the TV as Central as we can so
that you can see this up close and as
well as possible and we will show you as
much as we can about those nights as
well as possible
you will hear from the FBI
individual who was in the plane taking
that infrared video that shows the
defendant chasing Mr Rosenbaum and
initiating that confrontation
you will hear from other individuals who
took video that night so he yelled at
Rosenbaum that's your defense
yeah all I know he was running and he
ran down can we bring up the video while
still listening to this feed just the
audio of the video or is that what the
tricaster gonna bump it out um
you want just the uh just the video
without the audio so we can still listen
yeah which one uh I want the one where
the very first one when he runs past
Rosenbaum
so I don't know which one that is but
that's what I think he's talking about
because Cal renounce is running at one
point and he runs past Rosenbaum and
then Rosenbaum sees him and starts
pursuing him no that's the dumpster so
they're they're talking about FBI Drone
footage but the cowrin has defense fund
they just treated this look see he's
running by then he gets Chase so yeah
start playing that again from the
beginning here let's go in slow motion
see the puzzle in other words see this
look hold on a second watch watch watch
he runs by him and then Rosenbaum sees
him and starts chasing him throws his
hospital bag at him in other words it's
very clear there he's not running after
Rosenbaum he runs past and the guy goes
hey here's the guy who said I would get
now it's time for me to get him was a
shot there's a huge difference between
running past somebody and chasing them
right yeah the prosecution they're not
talking about the footage that we're
showing though they're talking about FBI
footage or they've had from they've had
for over five months but the cloud room
house defense fund tweeted that they
think this video will actually be good
for him yeah um
yeah we're going to show you the FBI uh
the FBI uh heat uh camera and it's just
like they show that we think this uh
yeah I think this is pivotal on this
show and it's just Rosenbaum next to
what appears to be a four-year-old
getting his phone looks like they're
taking a break they're opening statement
this is opening yeah and what an opening
statement it was you know what the truth
is look at this look hold on a second
let me show you let's see all these
Pages here that we have prepped and I
don't know if you can see this I don't
use a prompter but I have I have a bunch
of notes here and sources all the
references are available at lottery.com
uh I didn't need to do any of it the
prosecution just made our made the case
he went through our notes apparently
apparently he went through our notes
that was one of the finest jobs I've
ever seen that's called good lawyer I'd
rather have the public defendant from
Vinnie I'd rather have a public
defendant with a ponytail
yeah just the guy who replaced uh Cody
and step by step yeah
just uh you know you know honey is
preparing here for the common arguments
that we had been presented in the media
he didn't even make any of them no no no
I mean the most telling part to me is
keep in mind you guys can search right
now on YouTube Kyle Rittenhouse okay
any liberal Channel I'm not gonna name
names any liberal channel that includes
mainstream media and YouTube liberal
channels and they will as recently as
yesterday be saying and Kyle Rittenhouse
crossed brought a gun across state lines
you will find that yesterday the
prosecution's opening statement was and
Mr Black bought this for Kyle
Rittenhouse and kept it on
his family farm yeah in Wisconsin safe
in observance of the law like he just in
other words the prosecution's opening
statement just blew apart what the media
has been telling you because they didn't
compare notes if he had read our
anticipating argument section
he would have done a better job yeah
yeah it's like you could have settled
better research than they did yeah he
was like look I saw the video I don't
know I don't know I'm hoping that the
FBI is really my
Ace in the Hole really I just thought I
would refer to arson as a little bit of
it yeah and uh that did not slide the
way that I thought it would yeah the
judge like uh prosecution what's what's
your uh what's your game plan uh you
know just downplay the arson uh and
pedophilia and hope the FBI footage
really sees this yeah I gotta tell you I
don't know last night I cried me
something fierce your honor yeah I don't
know why I'm here I don't know if it's
hormones or whatever just the fact that
the uh the prospects of winning this are
increasingly Bleak I'll tell you the old
lady at home has a real real battle ax
she's a real the old battle action she's
really mad she says are you are you out
there defending pedophiles again and I
said yeah yeah
you know what was at the territory what
are you gonna do it's part of the job
prosecution doesn't have a Midwestern
accent
that's why my park benches and
billboards say 1-800 to Fan pedophile it
calls out before you finish the number
but it it it's it's a catchy and if in
my commercial I say you don't even have
to be a pedophile you could have just
rubbed the kid a little bit yep that's
right but I'm your man Call 555
longshank did you slip on a sidewalk
fall down the stairs at work or jack off
in front of a kid yeah
boy did you fall down slip down some
steps and accidentally grab a kid's boss
yes I mean it happens to the best of us
we know you did it just so you could get
up yeah and I mean your legs yeah
exactly
but in a cruel twist of fate you may
never walk again well these kids aren't
gonna unless themselves
I mean I can't believe how Gerald what
are your thoughts here by the way uh uh
you can uh please hey if you're watching
on YouTube smash that like button before
we go to Gerald because the media does
not want you to see this and uh they
want to make this age restricted from
showing the footage not so when the left
shows it and uh of course we're
available on Rumble if the stream gets
cut out always on Mud Club we'll take
your chat so there's two there's two
elements to this right so the first is
the initial altercation that would which
they just went through Great Links to
say was obviously self-defense
um I don't know why
um you established why Kyle was there to
protect businesses to help clean up to
render Aid because he had a kit you
established that there was a fire that
he has seen running with a fire
extinguisher towards you established
that he ran by your client or your the
people you're representing
um and that there was an altercation
where they threw stuff at him and chased
him down put his hands up Kyle then
points his gun at your I didn't know
this by the way he pointed the gun at
Rosenbloom or whatever his name was
Rosenbaum stops Kyle puts the gun back
down but the guy keeps coming after him
and then a gunshot happened two 2.6
seconds after let me ask you this two
seconds when you're running yes another
the prosecution just painted a picture
right he's like without his shirt on
tied on let me ask you this is the
picture that the prosecution just
painted let me ask you this okay
you're a miner you are not an adult okay
and you hear a gunshot okay in the
middle of night so you're not an adult
you're the kind of kid a pedophile would
want a screw just to be clear
okay you hear bang bang you turn around
and at the Forefront within the
background right in a soft focus lens
you have the entire city Ablaze you hear
gunshots and you see a shirtless Ginger
pedophile is there anything else more
technical retractingly scary that had
shot that has been running after you had
thrown stuff at you and was the shoot me
inward guy hey by the way the
prosecution goes and he puts his hands
up now I thought he was gonna say and he
put his hands up like saying hey I don't
want any trouble don't he says he
put his he put his hands up saying what
are you gonna do not like a challenge
but then he says Kyle didn't shoot him
and I'm like
so the guy stops and puts his hands up
Kyle says you can go basically I'm gonna
put my gun down but then the guy chases
him again and so Kyle starts running
again oh my gosh what is this guy what
is this I want to hear what they have to
say can we it's like it's like get some
real glass like spazzer it's like the
DeLorean broke gay Harry Potter
doing their job
Prosecuting people who break the law
it's not a circus it's not a show you're
not a circus okay
this is not funny
stuff that they're dealing with yeah why
didn't you just put on a pair of those
the judge's levity might be a little
tone deaf but is that a furry helmet
over there on the couch oh my gosh
[Laughter]
he's got he's got a different zoom in a
minute just because after the
prosecution's statement van Jones and
Navarro just dropped out like who can we
get uh Pink glasses guy oh my God you
mean the one who looks like Bruce
phalange screwed an alcoholic 50 year
old Harry Potter yeah isn't he a furry
well ask him to get it out of the frame
it's in the frame there's no time we
don't have time
he doesn't have the bow tie that goes
does he 'll do it as long as I can wear
my most fun glasses
wait you mean the glasses with the lines
that you can't see out of no no I didn't
say my second most fun classic
Oh you mean the ones with the big stars
like Elton John those are third
we've been through this you know you
said that to hurt me yeah we now go to
Elton John if he didn't make it
because he was told it's gonna be a long
long time yeah these are just they're
just doing the highlights which I don't
know can we use that term highlight can
basically they're saying Kyle
Rittenhouse is the defendant and so we
have it from the guy be like a highlight
for like ah we're gonna go to the uh
world champions highlight and it's just
a real of him getting submitted over and
over yeah oh well
not so much a highlight as now more so
we just have some footage and we need to
kill time yeah uh so that's the first
element of it right so Kyle his lawyer
needs to come up and say Kyle did in
fact come back around make sure somebody
was already administering Aid he got on
the phone because his friend was there
to watch his back oh my God I just shot
somebody and then sees oh that's right
there's other people that were chasing
me I'm getting the hell out of here I'm
going to get police basically he was
even saying like down there right yeah
so he starts running away so the second
element is people I don't care why they
were chasing him I don't care if they
thought he was a mass shooter I don't
care what none of that matters to his
actions they chase him he comes within
an inch of that skateboard hitting and
square in the head I know it's not you
he's on TV it's just unbelievable and
then he defends himself again there's no
way for them to make this case uh-oh I'm
wearing my masturbation glasses oops
these are the tube in addition
I thought those I thought those were
your flashing glasses now these are my
master patient glasses the flashing
glasses are green what is the bust he
says
really I'm sorry I was just filming too
such as the fact that prior to Mrs
we now go to the Center Square
is it a t-shirt
like I just sent this point TV and
people wonder look look you wonder why
people mistrust institutions it's like
Once Upon a Time an era of Walter
Cronkite Americans trusted their media
and I don't know why well okay all
right well I guess I catch fake memes on
Facebook on that someone
someone give me my route better get this
bird statue I need my ridiculous frame
it right no no no no no right shoulder
Ruth gator bait against my left shoulder
fun time later Ferry all right let's
take down the statues of the Angel kids
urinating
I'll just say they were in the
Confederacy what the hell is the
difference
David's look right over his head is that
like is that what is that a drawing of I
don't know I want to see that cartoon I
want to take a whole episode to go
through this guy's office but somebody
screen grab this we're going through
piece by piece
is that like what is it behind them oh
my gosh it looks like a cat with plus
and minus I I felt that the glasses
would distract from my disgusting I'm
never just out of a sheer morbid
curiosity wanted to be the magic mirror
on the wall right yeah for this hit
mirror mirror on the wall stop throwing
up
that's what the black caps are up
he's just actually taunting the news
because he's wearing evidence we don't
know about yet
boy these glasses sure do easily get
picked up on those FBI playing games and
as you can see with the heat map
behind this is awful I gotta tell you
look this is this is going to be the
narrative I guarantee
I should probably step out I'm gonna be
laughing I have to go to the bathroom
oh here's what I want
you can we order a pairs lenses I think
they might be for babies
why do I
oh my God I feel like under this guys
oh this guy's definitely Gone
Baby side by side by side I'm gonna die
the other baby was back I tell you what
if someone finds that listing on a child
like a child website like I don't know
Gymboree or Gap baby I swear I'm gonna
die this is amazing I'm gonna die all I
ask is that you do not look under my
crawl space for tiny skeletons stop it
his house so drafty well I just put
insulation between these walls and waste
all that space boy you got a septic leak
or something no leave I've seen sicario
two just the funny thing isn't going
from him to Cal Rittenhouse it just
makes one of them look legitimate if he
had a pinwheel
it's like a gay Cheshire Cat
thank you
thank you for visiting Wonderland
just puts on his tail and stands on top
of a cabinet like a clock yes now if
you'll excuse me I just puts on cat ears
and starts removing his shirt
I've got to go to work it did you just
got back he's just buttering his chest
oh my God
I'm sorry I thought I was sorry I if I
stood up accidentally screen shares his
next day ordering nipple wax
for people my not size shape yes it's a
shape now that he's off do you want to
um bring the ridden house challenge I
really have to pee for him let's do that
can we take a quick we're gonna take a
quick break uh two minute break I'm
going to go to the bathroom and we are
going to come back and before since
we're gonna have a while before the next
opening statements from the defense but
I repeat myself at this point uh we are
going to do the Kyle Rittenhouse
challenge where we are going to right
here in this space have four of our
employees see if they can make that
unbelievable shot just have to go uh
just have to go take a tank oh we'll be
back
foreign
[Music]
s like my wife's womb you're not the
first one to say that Jorge
[Music]
foreign
there's no time to argue throw me the
build bars
you have no choice hurry
[Music]
you stupid hey it's mine now
oh no Dr Jones
poison
[Music]
foreign
oh my gosh I was still laughing so hard
I pissed all over the floor
bathroom yeah and hey by the way we have
a ton of you watching on YouTube and I
think we have about 14 000 of you right
now yeah well here's the thing just so
you know I don't care where you watch
but I would like to see more of you on
you know on Rumble than YouTube if you
can yeah because those people they can
take it off at any time for something
special how many times quarterback
Garrett how many times have we had a
stream killed Oscars several debate
streams oh yeah every single time we do
this and we could honestly be removed
for saying that Kyle Rittenhouse was
practicing self-defense we have no idea
how YouTubers or those silly glasses
meanwhile whatever pink gay Harry Potter
glasses
that was one of the funniest things that
I have seen in a long time by the way
Trigger Discipline every single time do
you see his face every time all these
pictures they're using you're not we
didn't have it up but every time every
time his finger this is this is how you
want somebody to operate the Prisoner of
Azkaban was just Ronald Weasley in his
basement unbelievable I have him on a
Vietnamese hammock
okay people just tuning in it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense TV was the
funniest thing I think I've ever seen oh
yeah oh my gosh in my 34 years of
existence that was their expert I'm
waiting on Dave because he's going to
the bathroom but he has a prostate the
size of a basketball that's a big
prostate is the guy still that's not a
compliment there he is oh never mind
that's the opposite oh no no it's the
cloud oh my gosh
don't look when you come in don't look
you can't look at it he's gonna just die
laughing but then when you heard more
it'll always make like an Ernest face
now like he's disappointed imagine if
that was your father and he found out
that you know you broke curfew yeah and
he's like I'm disappointed in you son
you know the
my dad you know the Crowder name used to
mean something
what's the guy with the glasses in Harry
Potter that uh that picks up Harry and
tries to save him and he's licking his
lips all the time oh maybe he lays one
here's a monocle never mind anyway
there's one person in Harry Potter yeah
not him yeah he doesn't have glasses
it's just a one Wild Thing yeah never
mind all right let me hear it looks like
him maybe this guy is just such a
brilliant common type this look even
that we've all well we've wrongfully
prejudged it let's hear what he has to
say take this apart each set is going to
focus
on coins that justify their position so
for Kyle Rittenhouse he's gonna be able
to provide evidence
cut off his triple chins
that he was there with law enforcement
protecting a community and he's going to
have all the right looks like an Adam
Sandler character
he's going to testify yes I pay Jack and
Jill and then I go down to burn down to
Five Below station
[Applause]
[Music]
Target chain that's what he looks like
charges and and that's why the bullet
entry wounds are the way that they're
going to be and it's absolutely possible
to have a back entry
um bullet wound with self-defense just
generally it's not the first shot yeah
it's gonna be so you just said that it's
irrelevant because he shot Rosenbaum
several times he was shirtless and he
could have then spun around in other
words everything they're saying is
couched this is this is like it's
difficult for them you could tell
they're almost like philosophers we're
at the end of it Brian Keller said this
where they say at the end like oh or not
whatever
that's you know post-modernism right now
they're basically couching everything
and now the wound if in fact it did
enter through the back could be very
damning of course there are many
self-defense shots that have entry
points in the back because in the melee
uh people turn around uh so it could be
entirely innocent uh right yeah waiting
on that FBI Drone footage really we'll
see that well the only thing the FBI
Drone footage is going to prove they say
is Kyle written out started the initial
Thing by yeah
exactly well exactly they're saying oh
it's his fault because he's going to
know he was going back down towards the
place where that guy said he was gonna
you know maybe light on fire yeah right
and and you know he was trying to defend
that property so it makes perfect sense
I I honestly I mean if you're the
defense or I'm sorry if you're the
prosecution in this like this comes
across the desk do you wanna I Wanna
Know Why the the district attorney is
not trying this why is the assistant D
up there or is he sitting at the desk
and letting this guy take open because
the D.A wants to maintain a winning
record yeah he's like oh the Kyle ridden
house case
my first big
I need to find that out because that
would tell me everything I need to know
like uh you know I'm gonna be sick that
day he's a paralegal
I
who's in third time gave it to his CPA
Carl we've already here we go yeah you
know you have a bad mail room from Devry
that's good enough yeah don't worry
we're gonna mail you it we're gonna mail
you a beta tape of the FBI uh plane
footage you'll be fine
right oh where's Dave we need Dave here
for the Kyle Rittenhouse challenge
where's Dave can someone send Dave in
here yeah he's coming back well I know
he's coming back but I need him to be
back here no he left hey guys two out
there in the edit Bay uh and the
research you guys just send me because
I'm not really using this document since
they screwed it yeah they've already
used something you think that I need to
reference that I haven't hit uh yes for
crying out loud I mean he kind of they
didn't make any arguments kind of took
all our points from this kind of Defense
I wonder what the defense is thinking
right now like the lawyer's like huh
well I've been doing this a while and
that's never happened he's just saying I
knew I should have locked my notes
that's the last time I store my my
opening statement notes in the iCloud
should use the VPN all right Dave get to
your seat Mister just don't look at this
on the screen Mr piss and razor blades
no don't look at it
still there
oh my god oh no I love it oh there's and
Dave is back ladies
wow look at those facts yes oh party
glasses Mr writtenhouse no it's our
expert it's our expert
consultant yeah our chief I like Mrs
Potato Head glasses
what question did you have I'm a that
next did you prefer Mrs Pac-Man to Mr
Pac-Man because she was less threatening
uh I prefer uh neither Pac-Man because I
don't see gender ah what I do see your
point is you yeah my pants that's when
you start playing Pitfall
I'm gonna wear these
foreign
do we know when they're coming nope I'm
gonna do it all right okay so now look
we are going to because I can't do it
with you like that
and by the way they're still not as
silly look at me they're still not as
silly look at the guy was actually
wearing
he said
[Laughter]
you could have anyone on Earth yes look
how excited he is at the edge of his
seat Fort TV ladies and Gentlemen by the
way uh not a chance that Facebook checks
that Facebook checks their Facebook
lives which are meta live stream as a
non-authoritative
okay all right what we are going to do
right here uh for everyone watching
we're gonna tweet this out let everyone
know on social because this is something
I think a lot of people don't appreciate
a point that I've made in the past
bridled power bridled strength and that
is relevant because when someone makes
the kind of shot shooting someone in a
bicep like that under stress managing a
um you know clearing around from
effectively a jam in his rifle
um
or malfunction to for all the gun people
who like it's a magazine not a clip
um I think that's important to note
because it's important to understand
that if someone is operating from a
position of power then you have to take
into account
Mercy you have to take into account
control and patience and I think an
unbelievable amount of that was shown by
Cal Rittenhouse just because of how
capable he was so just to see how many
people here in this office are capable
it is time to take the Rittenhouse
challenge
[Music]
all right okay so we are going to have
uh our employees here yes Safety First
Safety First yes
Safety First yeah you're going to do uh
hey I I don't you have a pair of glass
yeah I know I have glasses you're fine
these are Bullets by the way do lick
these I can't even see through them I
lick them they're special glasses I
licked all the glasses you don't want to
know what was on there before leave them
in a room with Rosenbaum and little
tumblers oh geez okay I left him in a
sauna yeah all right so what we are
going to do here is place four four
people right there tokenau in the same
scenario that Cal Rittenhouse found
himself right and see if they're able to
make this shot in the biceps so uh who
is first who's going here we can bring
in our uh bring in our antifa black
lives matter thugs you guys come on in
come on in take your positions
and we are going to place Kyle
Rittenhouse on the floor do you guys
need to adjust the cameras there
hold on one second let me make sure that
we have the cameras adjusted because
we're kind of all right there we go okay
so uh oh Austin Choice us okay you are
going on the floor today you are our
Kyle ritten house I can tell by the Hat
um okay you are going to be let me get
make sure I have these names correct
here you're gonna be Mr
and you are Mr skateboard
I get the names confused let me make
sure I have Joseph Rosemount dress who
gives a the guy who hits him with
this I just you don't look I'm very bad
with names uh this is we're going to
recreate the scenario the guy comes in
hits Cal Rittenhouse with the skateboard
in the head and then when I say go I'll
give you guys a countdown then you will
need to Austin you will need to clear a
malfunction so to simulate that and
don't worry it's not an Alec Baldwin
thing these are Nerf guns uh that you
couldn't put a live round in there
accidentally even if your brother
William was on set and had a few wild
turkeys
um you are going to have to turn around
and make sure the timing is correct
where your rifle cannot be aimed at Mr
Krusty Kratz
cross-dressed creatures uh until he is
within one foot of you and aims yeah one
second they may be doing the defense
opening statements right now let's check
check real quick I think it's on there
right now
um taken by Nathan de broon of Josh's
excuse me I said Joshua Joshua well I
hope not and is this the defense bomb
starting a fire at the trailer I think
they might be objective and in that one
all right let's go to at least the first
round of this and then you guys can let
me know keep an eye on it so are you
ready you know you guys know your rules
you cannot shoot him police anywhere
outside of the bicep until he is close
to you yeah you found the weapon is uh
Avail is you know visibly
available to you all right okay so I'm
going to count down Kyle right now's
challenge in three two
all right skateboard his head brain V
okay boom okay clear malfunction now go
see if we can get in the bicep nope you
missed you missed he missed
bounced off his hands went that was
appropriate that was appropriate all
right sorry Choi better luck next time
at the range okay again the the attempt
here is to shoot the bicep
all right let's bring in number two
Bryce let's see the goal here and by the
way you were waiting you were being way
too generous he had way more time than
Cal Rittenhouse actually had right we we
know yeah you guys don't need to wait
for Stephen to give you cues we can just
do it like we did in rehearsal just yeah
yeah once I say three two one just go
yeah the first one is ready to fire
Bryce all right yeah all right hold on
start the music
and when I say three two Cal Rittenhouse
challenge brain him with the skateboard
okay now up bicep only bicep only oh
where'd you shot your own dick
riders win again
that's not even a joke he actually shot
him he said he did yeah inner thigh wow
better luck next time
shot himself just keep in mind how
capable this Written House must be I
mean unbelievable I mean we're doing
this a lot slower it's like these guys
are moving in Taffy he might have been
scared
who's next well I don't know they have
to reload it load reload apparently we
got the Nerf musket
you have to pack it can we do we get a
big enough clip yeah we got a big enough
clip all right are you ready there even
Brendan oh look he's got a good he's got
a good stance he's really going for it
you can see how how dead he really wants
to do it all right get the music going
Kyle Rittenhouse Challenge and you can
try this at home kids with Nerf guns uh
in three two Braden V boom skateboard
trying to get the gun okay get the bicep
get the bicep get the butt oh no no you
shot him in the heart oh that was pretty
close I'm gonna give it to him come on
no I'm not gonna give it to him come on
good job Brent well I guess okay that's
better than the others that is you did a
good job now how do you think you would
have done it if you uh if you if they
were if it was a you know you had just
been chased by a shirtless pedophile and
they were actually trying to kill you
probably worse probably worse yeah let's
imagine that your your heart is just
pounding in your chest adrenaline is
running you're running down the street
you get tagged basically you get hit
from behind you then end up falling
loose I'm not talking about Rosenbaum
we're not allowed to bring up his past
people no no not him I'm talking about
something
listen I get it hey but then he never
listens that's his problem like you
wheel around and that that's I I would
never be able to make that shot I would
have been like oh God help me no there's
no way shooting everywhere good good
attempt there Brandon though you were
pretty close but you killed him oh so
you'd have another murder charge well
yeah yeah that's true hey by the way how
did you you feel have you been watching
how do you feel the prosecution
statements have been uh I don't know I
feel like they're they're they got a
they got some kind of uh Prestige going
on or otherwise they're idiots
okay all right that's good all right
even Brendan
do you have anything weaker because I've
been like covering graffiti all day and
like I'm I'm pretty I'm pretty tired do
you have anything to like oh yeah that's
right I would imagine shooting pedophile
stuff is is hard work you know what it's
difficult yeah
I tell you what after a long hard day of
shooting uh
child sex offenders what is it I
replenish with built bar oh nice there
you go yeah it's got protein and it
doesn't have a ton of sugar but real
dark chocolate and you look you don't
need a protein bar you can eat anything
but we don't really have a lot in a
snack box and it tastes like dessert so
go to buildbar.com and use it what's the
promo code there built.com use crowder15
for 15 off your next order built.com
sorry buildbar.com is hardcore
pornography yeah don't don't put that in
build.com and use a promo code Crowder
to get a discount how does that feel in
your mouth
[Music]
listen Bill Barton they pay for that I
think I'm ready to go uh go back in the
streets yeah okay all right let's take
it go take it to the streets I like to
watch him chew
and we don't have many sponsors these
things are delicious you put them in the
freezer and look everyone like out there
like we're going to prove you don't need
to use protein bars it's just if I use
these in replacement of candy bars oh
yeah because it's just as tasty that
double chocolate or the new cookie duck
that's got some good protein to it and
it's filling it's perfect the only thing
I'll say is don't get the birthday cake
I don't like it listen that's you that's
just me but I don't like birthday cake I
like the birthday cake yeah that's
because you're a jerk you should be
wearing pink Harry Potter glasses well
get your get your favorite flavor at
build.com use creditor 15. yeah Crowder
15 you get 15 off just try them they're
delicious yeah I love real dark
chocolate I like the mint chocolate chip
yeah that one's pretty good with a
peanut butter fudge can they do the mix
box online that's on there right can
they do the mix box I think so check it
out we got the mix box we have the mix
box if I say the mix box it's pretty
delicious yeah like I said you don't
need it but if you're like I want to cut
back on candy bars built.com not
builtbar.com that's just a video
and then there's a mystery flavor on the
front page no what what is that what
that's not Rosenbaum
is it shake of Arrow it's injected it's
something I came up with yes exactly yes
it's Bruce phalange ball hair oh
all right seriously look I appreciate
that you're taking your life in your
hands he ordered why Fox food
Mystery Box food well build bar you can
trust they're going to give you
something I I know I still wouldn't no
okay I feel like you're signing all all
legal liability there if you're like I'm
like sure yeah yeah there's a lot of
mixed boxes better than right mystery
all right so is the defense what are
they doing right now what are we
monitoring this photograph is it still
photograph of can someone there in the
control room tell us exactly what's
going on here are they submitting
evidence as far as like exhibit a
exhibit B is that what's going on
and the next photograph is him kicking
Kyle in the head
30 here's the picture looks like he's
going over with each article piece of
evidence is 31. no this is prosecution
attorney number two
thank you Mr Huber striking can you let
me know is there anything they're
missing guys because I just feel like
I've been cut off at the knees by how
idiotic right there yeah they're
submitting photo evidence right now oh
they're submitting photo evidence the
jury's not in there objects to defense
photos an opening statement
while he's grabbing Kyle's gun his bare
hand
touching Kyle's gun with his left hand
that is not code word he was actually
touching a weapon yeah just picking jump
kick man getting up jumping around they
don't know who he is Mr Huber with his
hand once again on the gun going forward
and still having a skateboard
33 is a close-up of that photo
34 is
you can see the strap on Mr
rittenhouse's gun being pulled taut Mr
gross quits running into the frame from
the right of the frame next is Gage grow
squids standing in front of Kyle
Rittenhouse with his hands up Kyle does
not shoot next Gage grow squids
lunges forward with his right hand
pointing directly what photos did they
object to because this is pretty bad and
they're not objective
your honor I object on what grounds this
really screws my case yeah okay no
please I object what uh to exhibit
number four could we change the tint in
that a little bit
or maybe maybe a puppy filter
I'd like to make my clients all look a
little less threatening yeah
skateboard with a pillow and a gun with
a water pistol I tell you what though
this makes it very very clear if this
kid
if they hang this kid oh it's entirely a
political uh a political charging a
political conviction I'm getting on a
plane and I am peacefully protesting and
I don't say that is any code word
anything let me be very clear I am
protesting I I'm exercising my rights
I'm getting on a plane I'm going to
Wisconsin oh look at this guy it's the
first time I saw a straight on he looks
like he looks also a little bit like the
uh the one guy who's in uh uh in in Oh
Brother Where Art Thou we thought you
was a toad
sites they'll have the opportunity to
call witnesses to talk about these
things we will have an opportunity in
closing arguments to characterize these
things but teachers do it themselves to
give the the jury what the defense
considers and I'm not conceding that
these things are the all photographs or
even that a lot of these things are
relevant
um but for for the opening statement to
essentially be the entire defense case
the evidence we're showing it to them is
highly unusual
um
not pushing the envelope as far as I
should have uh but it's the defense
wants to show all photos and videos in
their opening statement the prosecution
is objecting to that oh yeah well the
prosecution can go piss up a rope I'm
not giving them the evidence that's what
that's because you don't have any you
can only have it if you reference was
the evidence they just submitted outside
of this mythical Drone footage sorry FBI
plane can you say I'm not giving the
evidence you know
Twitter has banned the hashtag Kyle
Rittenhouse really try when you try it
just says Kyle Richards that's the only
one you can put in who the hell is Kyle
Richards I don't know but you can't you
can't really yeah you can't use it maybe
that guy with the pink glasses let me go
see if anyone watched my what the
as a general policy wow hey good Twitter
thanks Twitter for ghosting it this is
what happens they make sure that it
Trends right when everyone's saying this
kid's a murderer and all the false
evidence was being presented right
evidence out of context when before we
had more video footage than you could
watch in a lifetime now when and that's
also by the way in admission that the
prosecution sucks because I haven't even
heard the defensive statements and so
they saw the prosecution's opening
statements one uh we better redirect
this to Kyle Richards and there's some
kid named Kyle Richards right now at a
school going what the trending
everywhere no you can't even put in
written house
Rittenhouse Kyle Rittenhouse nothing
let's see if you can put in Kenosha
you put in Wisconsin
Illinois
I love that we've only let's see what he
said the prosecutions opening arguments
and they're like we got to get this
hashtag yeah exactly yeah cut it this is
awesome look at how they behave in the
face of evidence
and I want to hear his ruling
going to be relevant beyond our relevant
they've all been
it sounded like what I've already heard
about it uh by and large you know the
standard is not what you did or what you
can do or could do the standard is what
the law allows and I can remember
um
studying this 50 years ago that this was
an acceptable way with judicial
permission to make an opening statement
we see it more in civil cases and in
criminal it's
a customary in
um
criminal cases but I've seen it done by
your office
oh you're right this is a record number
in terms of the numbers but on the other
hand there's record there's a large
number of crimes being charged in
separate acts that are being asserted
with respect to both the acts that the
state alleges were unlawful and the
defendant's claim of self-defense so
um given what that they do appear all to
be relevant and they've been agreed as
authentic then I don't see any reason
that I should interfere with his right
to make an opening statement Mr finger
maker makes a good point in reinforcing
my comment that this is supposed to be
brief and informative
so keep it I think I'll be any longer
than him
it's your honor bless you yeah very
happy very happy
that guy is an Stephen I feel
like the next thing that we are going to
hear from the the prosecutor is the
state would like to drop all charges
she gets like I love how it goes uh and
I've seen this done before uh by your
your office hey today today's a big win
for the Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
because that is who Kyle Richards is
associated with oh good for her
someone's getting some Chardonnay in the
face chick named Kyle what is that yeah
well the folk song fake tits and spit
takes
the fact that Mr Rosenbaum saw miss
swart that night and was basically was
not allowed to stay with her or did was
not uh able to stay with her that night
so he left her residence and I purposely
warded it that way your honor because
there are many reasons why someone may
not
be able to stay at someone's residence
maybe there's a child within 500 yards
yeah that's a lot of reasons I left my
frosted tips at home
to go into this he believes I've opened
the door to it I wanted a prince I go
into Supercuts and ask for the Nick
Lachey this was one of the things that I
said it's going to be mentioned he's
going to try to go into it because I
mentioned it there's a lot of reasons
why you can't stay at somebody's house
right oh because your son was there yeah
I do not good my statement open the door
to it and frankly my statement is not
evidence
um so I don't know they can really open
the door anyway but by and large I was
very careful in the way I worded that
and I don't think it opened the door I
don't think regardless this is a
relevant issue uh for this trial here's
the thing about that we're just in my
statement as an Evidence and I
understand what he's saying though
the defense's opening statements is uh
evidence exhibit a evidence exhibit B
evidence Exhibit C evidence exhibit D
evidence exhibit e and then the
prosecution goes well hey he can't
submit all that evidence my statements
aren't
stay there I love it and not why can't
we tell the jury why because there was a
no contact it's not appropriate he
thinks he didn't open the door but
because he's a pedophile just so you
know and he also talked about the
hospital got out of the hospital he was
in Minnesota and he's going to put her
on the witness stand and we're not going
to get to ask that sorry you did open it
I mean that's insane can I retract my
statement your honor I did not say it I
would like to can I get a new jury
please uh Ray Scott he is right it's
like we can't say that he's a pedophile
leaving a mental hospital you said he
should have been in jail what he did is
he was he was like I do want to hear
this okay he made him look like a victim
yeah whether or not Mr Rosenbaum needed
uh new kidney or needed medications for
mental illness or was going to have his
blood pressure checked has nothing to do
because all the blood pressure
and suggesting to this jury that it is a
character there's there's an allegations
show those again illness that
that had something to do with his
behavior that night it did you say
mental illness you're an expert on by
the way I guess if they want to try
there are a lot of people who are
mentally ill who don't sexually abuse
children that's the problem with the
term mental illness and they go we need
to we need to unstigmatize mental
illness sure but then the left always
wants to say but this is why you wonder
why the con why conservatives say you
know what the left whether I said this
yesterday knowingly or unknowingly if
they are unknowing Rubes are going to
eventually normalize pedophilia this
trial is an experiment in that because
you know what in any other civilized
society Rosenbaum would have long since
been executed just to be clear just to
be clear five kids five kids later I was
gonna say something else but I can't say
five kids too many well no it's it's
it's definitely yeah five kids too many
you know with me
you get away with one kid no you don't
screw a kid once shame on you
I'm gonna stay out of this screw a kid
twice shame on me all right let's see
what screw a kid three times I will be
the prosecutor win a pair of glasses
just think about this put this in the
evil context that it is recall those
because I didn't have to put too much
thought into it but uh I thought that
the references or the statements which
were attributed to Mr Rosenbaum where I
just got out of jail today
uh you're telling me that too it was
there was also a discussion about
Hospital
no no or there's there's no video or
statements or audio of Mr Rosenbaum
talking about the hospital the only
relevance it has your honor you brought
it up you did it was there is a there is
is there testimonial
uh are we going to hear testimony that
he was in his opening statement jail
that day there's going to be statements
to that effect okay your statement on
your
on your um
statement was and and I will tell you
this I want to I'm going to ask you to
try to reconstruct from you if necessary
I'll have the reporter read it but
I don't I I don't recall the exact
statement I do know that I thought at
the time I'm surprised he's going into
this because it may trigger a he's
telling me I remember thinking this
guy's a I'm like whoa
okay oh this guy I remember thinking in
my head I didn't say it because you know
I want to be polite I remember thinking
this guy doesn't even this Prosecuting
an attorney the district attorney
assistant doesn't even have room
temperature IQ
I was thinking uh there's this
difference between getting your blood
pressure checked and being incarcerated
in a hospital by the state yeah yeah
yeah there's a difference between you
know you know I was thinking in my head
being on dialysis and raping a kid I
know you know there's uh really heads or
tails of it yeah you know can't make
heads or two I get it it's all your
point the typical how is your blood
pressure no no no I hear his not so good
now oh he just pissed off what did he
say what did you do
that he couldn't stay with her and so
then he left and essentially came
downtown and Miss swore will testify and
she will talk he couldn't stay with her
I'm sorry why did you say that he
couldn't stay with her he didn't I said
that because it explains why he didn't
know why in downtown he's got a hospital
bag your honor there's it's up to Kyle
yawning I think for someone to be
released from a hospital have a bag of
their personal belongings go to their
girlfriend's Place either continue to
walk around with it
um that is highly unusual that sounds
like somebody with a mental illness
mental illness can we take that off the
table he's a pedophile well that's true
that's the same it's really not what was
in his bag uh tactical flashlight and
Bernstein Bears Oh you mean the worst
kind of sex offender yeah or a guy who
might have been a little depressed yeah
yeah that this is a Molotov cocktail or
it's got chemicals in it or some it's
got something that could cause the
defendant harm it had his penis
mouthwash water bottle did he have his
penis on him the narrow wait by the way
relevance of this bag no that's why the
mouth
the mouthwash wasn't for him it was just
mouthwashing Astro Glide and a little uh
a bunch enough candies to leave a trail
and some small handcuffs from Chuck E
Cheese's more of a Chinese finger trap
really it might just
for a suicide attempt so and
oh let the jury know what type of
hospital it was acting a favor he was he
was not might be irrelevant that's part
of the defense he said it was a suicide
attemption says can't stay there why
can't he stay there because there's a
quarterback you don't get out of a
hospital for a suicide apartment
stay in it
right but he hasn't been tried or
convicted of that because he's deceased
but your honor oh yeah
Hitler's never been tried and convicted
because he's already dead what a
criminal case started so you know if if
we wanted us all a favor
come on that's true but again it doesn't
make him a criminal on this evening it
doesn't make his behavior yes it does
he's on a registered
he's gonna judge a rule
I don't
think
as far as your opening statement you
need to respond to his statement about
the hospital I'll have to separately
decide at a later Point as to whether
the whether he had been hospitalized and
for what I don't know if that's
admissible or not I suspect that it is
not
but I'll keep an open mind uh and
um
as far as here as he is not being there
or not supposed to be there again I'm
not sure that I want to hear about that
in your opening statement but
um
uh again I'll hear you later as to why
do you think that so he's putting it off
okay because he's talking about my
client traveling here from out of bounds
and he's trying to say oh he had a good
excuse for not being at home he couldn't
stay there that night well the jury
should know why he couldn't stay there
well I don't know if you can't stay
there he can't stay there she could have
kicked him out because she didn't like
this is a Serial pedophile he's having a
hospital bag I don't know
she didn't like his bag because he was
trying to put it over her head
no he makes a good point though it
doesn't need to be addressed in the
opening statement right then you can
just frame it however you want it was
really stupid
fan of his ball bag later on
oh is that a phone call is he phoning
you hello
would you come down please yes okay oh
he's bringing the jury back I forgot
there's covid yeah
where's your turtle shell mask like the
last guy oh yeah yeah
oh my gosh I feel like this guy's about
to pop a Werther's original in his mouth
and it'd be a great ad yeah
um
and I understand it but it also it is
when you bring it up as a prosecution it
is relevant like well he left the
hospital why it was mentally unstable
suicide attempt which doesn't make sense
they don't usually discharge you if you
have a suicide attempt to usually keep
you there if you're going to go through
the past the leading up events of Kyle
then why can't you but my point is that
reason my guess is he was discharged
from the hospital because it was a
threat to others he said that he was
discharged from the hospital for a
suicide yeah that's not how it's what he
said that's not how it works at all you
don't try to kill yourself and they go
you can go right well I so I think what
they meant was he was in the mental
hospital because suicide oh okay and
then was discharged but he was
discharged they're acting recklessly
yeah on here did you hear the reasoning
that he was saying he's saying he threw
a bag at him and he's like people have
said that the bag had like chemicals in
it or maybe weapons of some I'm sorry
what I've I've searched tying low sir I
have not heard one person say that there
was a bomb in the bag or any kind of
chemical warfare was taking place oh
some people were saying he no cut a hole
in the bottom of the bank's tank he fit
and told people to reach in for popcorn
yeah there's no evidence of that I mean
you're the prosecuting attorney
you could have said he threw a bag with
toiletries at Kyle Rittenhouse problem
solved toiletries that's what you say is
in there too space mouthwash a water
bottle you didn't have to say his
hospital bag to make it look like a
victim I thought there were socks in the
bag that was what I had read he didn't
say there were socks no but my point is
I assumed it was the lightest fluffiest
object possible
unless it was Turkish cotton pillowcases
yeah I don't know how it could be
gentler than throwing it back it doesn't
matter 1000 thread count yeah it doesn't
matter bamboo sheets maybe I don't know
bamboo sheets more sustainable they're
very very comfy yeah all right let's see
what they're saying here what are they
doing right now contact order at his
residence that's
what significant
restraining order or was it because of a
child can someone bring it up the reason
for the no contact order because it's
really hard when you have a guy who's
you know you have all of these guys who
were shot every single one beat someone
who was uh more helpless hey you guys
about punching down does raping
kids and strangling women count just
want to be clear no I don't think so
yeah
Kyle Rittenhouse is a mistake because he
didn't shoot Dave Chappelle yeah that's
true
need to tell you and show you what I
believe the evidence will show
you've heard the states opening
statement and now I will give mine we
have two very different
not really how it looks on the events of
August 20th not as different as I
thought 20. it's filling in holes Kyle
Rittenhouse that's present in Kenosha
Wisconsin on the evening of August 24th
he stayed at his friend's residence
Dominic black he saw on the live streams
and things like that the events of the
24th
saw a car source
number one as I refer to it the one
that's on
the east side of Sheridan Road burned
all of the automobiles burned
destroyed yep we covered that
going on he saw the other businesses
burnt down and the prosecutors went down
to downtown Kenosha to look at the
damage he stopped any
help clean up
at the old Ruther High School I think
it's called something else now but when
I was around here objection he also
cleaned the grade school at the record
show thank you he met one of the owners
from car source and they talked and they
decided that they would offer their
services him and Dominic black and Nick
Smith to help protect the property of
car Source ladies and gentlemen the
evidence will show in spite of what the
media and public statements and things
like that have been the evidence will
show that Kyle Rittenhouse had strong
ties to Kenosha his father lived in
Kenosha his mother lived in Antioch
Illinois Kyle worked here in Kenosha
County at the Rec Plex in Pleasant
Prairie as a lifeguard
he went downtown to clean up the
graffiti him and Nick left there and
they decided to come back that evening
and help car Source Lot 2 which is at
59th and Sheridan and initially car
Source 3 at 60th and Sheridan
and it's just for a second the people
who were shot look at their rap sheet I
think if you add up all of the January
6th riots the charges they still don't
equal just the rap sheet of the three
people that he shot yeah much less it
reads like it reads like an episode of
lockup and if you read the the
motivations behind Kyle right now so
what he did in the 24 hours preceding
these events it reads like a merit badge
list yeah yeah lifeguard doesn't work
stayed late cleaned up graffiti brought
a medic kit rescued a cat in a tree
helped an old lady cross the road
by the way this is from The New York
Times regarding that no contact order uh
rosenbaum's fiance had pressed charges
against him a month earlier after a
fight in which he knocked her down and
bloodied her mouth if Rosenbaum violated
his no contact voter she warned he could
be sent back to jail so just like Jacob
Blake it's the circle of dicks well I
think it would be extremely relevant
then because it shows that he's violent
yes not only with children with children
he's aroused with women he's violent
right because he's mad that they're not
children correct yeah
where's your lunch pail it's actual or
imminent I told you to wear the Cabbage
Patch doll I don't see how that would be
irrelevant I mean that that would show
you that he's dangerous and there's a
reason why he felt fear you mean it's
not relevant that he was wandering the
streets because he was discharged from
an insane asylum and his wife slash
girlfriend wouldn't allow him in the
house because he beat the out of
her that's not relevant to whether he
attacked someone for crying out loud if
I leave the house to cool off in a bad
mood there's a good a chance I'm hitting
someone who's driving and texting but if
somebody's Chasing After You
if somebody's chasing after you to hurt
you you don't stop and go can I see your
criminal record just so I know how to
evaluate the situation right yeah if
you've ever defended yourself you've
never done that right any case of
self-defense without a shirt and it tied
around his head like Lords of a radius
this guy seems nutty doing a luau dance
smacking his thighs and you go you know
what I think I'm gonna put a couple
rounds of two two three through this
yeah
it's important in this Photograph
Squirtle poop
he's obviously he's obviously currently
wearing him and his fictitious lat
spread Mr Rosenberg yeah he looks good
and these are the best shots
that's what he said
along with other individuals started all
the women
put that dumpster that was very close to
a gas station out
Mr Rosenbaum became enraged
your honor the Clickers
explain the clip
I'm gonna go back
the sound on
this is so Midwest yeah they neither one
of them are banging outside to be honest
okay here we go They're not going to
play it over the uh oh Court TV yeah
because he repeatedly says the n-word
yeah shoot me he was
[Music]
don't you love the two black guys don't
do anything no they don't do anything
and I'm not saying that it gives you
right to beat someone up if they say
that there's no reason to ever assault
someone unless you're in physical danger
but the point is if the guy has the
wrong team jersey on they'd swarm him oh
yeah I mean those not all black people
those black people who were there at the
riots you know near the near the fire at
a gas station I'm alone about they
wouldn't be too friendly if Kyle right
now or one of his buddies repeatedly
yelled the n-word just and that's an
inference
Trend or associate Joshua zaminski had
just come from starting
a trailer on fire
he arms himself
with a chain and goes up and down Double
Dragon Sheridan details oh I've not seen
this carrying this rather heavy chain uh
yeah that's a big chain elements you
seem to have left out I got bigger in
Gold but he has a hospital bag in the
other hand so he's nice so Rose that's
rosenbaum's chains rosenbaum's chain
that's why he's shirtless yeah I hadn't
I don't know had you guys seen this I
had heard about the chain but I hadn't
seen that image no I have not seen the
image and now it's like oh so you were
you had a weapon yeah yeah it's clearly
a weapon no obviously a weapon your name
is Alec Blaine and even mention it
what's that story it's true knives
chains zip guns bow which really rubber
band gun is the least of your concern at
that point mention it let's go in this
scenario on August 25th one creating
chaos and Havoc with Mr Rosenbaum havoc
and two more importantly when we finally
get to car Source number three Mr
zaminski is the individual who fires the
first shot that evening behind Kyle
Rittenhouse as he's being chased
by Mr Rosenbaum the only difference
between and what the prosecuting
attorneys have said Mr is that he
brought up that image of the chain Mr
zaminsky
starting the trailer on he's going to
retell it he's just going to fill in the
game along with the dumpster
show that that is in fact no he left out
chain mental and pedophile yeah yeah
those are the three Mad Libs
[Laughter]
you like per cheese once again
I don't play Jenga it makes me nervous
yeah that thing falls off Lord that's a
messy I don't want to clean up after
you've been doing your Chinese fondue
you know I like the hit matching the
pants
I'm just gonna say it's getting dressed
easy banana man is that a sword
you guys bring up some images from
Double Dragon the old Nintendo yeah it
was lesbians and Mohawks and guys with
chains I'm literally watching well not
Double Dragon like final fights of
orange yes yes Streets of Rage that's
what that's what it is a streets of Fury
Streets of Rage no Streets of Rage
fights for Fury
the point is it's like a side-scrolling
beat em up they're showing up with
flashlights pink Mohawks chains guns and
skateboards you ever played a
side-scrolling beat em up those are the
first levels before you get to the boss
who has a plasma rifle yeah I think one
guy showed up with a pool cue and was
like no I just want to come on
why is it snapped in half like I play
this new game called double pool yeah
two players I put on Pink glasses yeah
you never played double pull what are
you more of a snooker guy I call it a
pig roast there's one guy and one behind
me
oh geez
right yeah
or a chain
it's the exact same haircut yeah well
she was inspired yes she was inspired
standing right next to the guy from
Cypress Hill
anyway
insane the membrane but why was he there
he doesn't have his mask on guys
he's in China this was August of last
year there was a pandemic
which is still now
grow squids running
down Sheridan Road and you see his hand
going into the back
of his winging to the back
of his waistband pulling out a firearm
to arm himself so Gage has gauges
individual by the name of Nathan de
Bruin it's not as giving yellow dot
right up there is where Kyle Rittenhouse
is as they chase him down Sheridan Road
Mr gross quits is not in any danger
Kyle Rittenhouse has already told him
that he's going to turn himself into the
police
yet he arms and continues with the mob
to attack
this is a picture by the way he just
brought up something that you couldn't
know where he said he already told him
he was going to surrender the police we
couldn't know this so some of this is
new information there was no objection
just to be clear yeah so think of what
is not to what is not being objected
right now by the prosecution that's
absolutely just his telling and then as
he's laying prone on the ground he comes
in for another hit on his head and then
grabs Kyle writtenhouse's firearm to try
and take it away from him
the next photograph is a picture yeah
and I'm sure that guy was going to take
away his firearm and turn it into the
local authorities right skateboard
the trucks of that skateboard I'm gonna
hit you with it
that skateboard in front of you as
evidence today
because then you could see it you could
see the weight and the heft of what a
skateboard is and what that skateboard
would do is somebody takes it in their
hand and swings oh yeah you can do a lot
of the skateboard a special we used to
joke about it because uh I hit the
trucks well I had a Reese Forbes Element
skateboard I don't even know if he's
still around but he was like they used
to call him like the master of Holly he
just had the highest Ollies and uh so
it's back then you need a deck with a
lot of Pops so you get the reef and I
just I that's how I learned how to ollie
learn how to kickflip and I wasn't very
good I could do a couple of steps but
the edge of it gets so sharp on those
boards we used to joke about how you
know you would it's like it was like
yeah yeah you have an edge that's sharp
and then you also have solid metal
weights in there yeah wow you had a nice
skateboard I did not had element uh deck
I think it was it was a it's been a long
time independent trucks or Independence
trucks independent trucks and then I had
the industries with independent trucks
oh yeah there you go well and she's and
then I had the I had the uh not the
expensive Swiss bones bearings but the
Bones Brigade I think what uh what what
which one did Walmart sell that was
wrapped in plastic uh I don't know but
behind it they don't actually you're
right Bros Obama's hiding behind it like
you want The Lion King Board now I have
no home to go to because I beat her
but I just got out of the hospital
you had a terrible childhood
Kyle is laying oh yeah on the ground
moving everywhere getting horrible
skateboards
hitting him with the skateboard no no
this is a guy flying over him he's the
first guy comes in he flea approached
him and he was flying over him black
he's a you know he's a Robbie Knievel
fan close-ups of that jump kick man
black boots as he's kicking him in the
face Kyle fires and this man was shot no
no oh listen he gets up and he runs away
Into the Night Never that's a different
guy that's not the skateboard guy I
didn't know we're coming forward to
identify himself as a victim so many
people were assaulting him on the ground
it seems to be
this is very crazy look for him the
evidence will show the state looking
forward the evidence will show those are
the big players in this case but
ultimately what you'll end up having to
decide
looking at all the circumstances of that
evening are the events that occurred by
the way just so you guys people watching
you guys can comment we'll take your
comments on the blaze yeah
I think we only need to cover this and
then probably the actual verdict yeah I
think it's over unless yeah unless the
verdict oh sorry the jury is going to be
intimidated because of writing right I
cover that I can't see how this goes any
other way at this point because I
remember thinking they're going to hang
this kid I cannot see they maybe get him
on the Firearms charge maybe
so sure yeah well there's no statement
that if you go in that direction you're
a quarter black Oracle
I need to drink he's gonna drink his
water Like a Pill Kyle
an individual by the name Ryan Balch
followed by Richard McGinnis
go down there
Sheridan Road
this guy is so much more confident you
might as well just slap his balls on the
table see this please don't you see that
Mr Stark he actually crop dusted the
table as he walked into the podium here
for a little bit look at that Cypress
Hill and the individual in the yellow
pants
Kyle Rittenhouse
pointing a laser sight from a gun at him
Kyle shrugs it off does not want
confrontation with these individuals
does not Point his firearm and he leads
did they point a gun at him or a laser
light as a laser because he doesn't
after this we have that FBI footage and
it looks like the prosecution was just
slang what really really all right so
stay tuned guys because I've not we have
it is it publicly available how long has
it been publicly available
country I said oh no I should have
hired the Swedish trainers stop with the
Bleach I don't need it I'm already white
yeah I record 409. oh foreign
that's not what I ordered did you see my
news I figured I could choke myself yeah
I just this is unreal it just keeps
getting worse it's so bad so okay gosh
let me be clear with you guys because we
have and we have all the references
available at letterscard.com I'm always
very careful about not making a
statement definitively unless I can
substantiate it no one's perfect we've
all made mistakes yes I try and let you
know when I'm making an inference when
something is conjecture at that point
because I also have the right to do that
this is an entertainment show however I
did not know I would I was not able to
confirm that Rosenbaum had a chain they
just confirmed it so he in fact was
armed and plenty of people have been
killed with chains it used to be a very
common weapon here in the United States
back when the Jets and the Sharks ruled
the streets
before the uh before the uh folks of
color took over Harlem
um
it's better that way because the Jets
and the Sharks Foy those were dangerous
times uh and then uh just right now they
talked about a guy pointing a laser at
him they showed a noose I had not seen I
had heard people talk about a noose was
not able to find the pictures and if I
found them was not able to confirm the
authenticity so we know Rosenbaum had a
chain we know there was a noose the only
thing the prosecution brought up
if you guys have watched this stream and
people can rewind it the only thing you
guys were here of Interest was I said
what's that FBI plane put it yeah
so now you're saying we have it tokono
and how long has that been publicly
available because he said it had not
been publicly available
yes I was just watching it uh we we got
this posted today okay okay so the
prosecution attorney is so shitty
that he also got it wrong when he says
not publicly available
Discovery what it leaked no
all right I mean it could have been when
he started but I doubt it yes you know I
mean that's
that's the one benefit of the doubt I'll
give him thus far
all right let's go back to the defense
uh but again he's just all he's doing is
repeating what the prosecution said and
showing pictures yeah yeah is like
chains yeah that's a picture of him from
a video leaving the car Source at 11 46
PM approximately he has his fire
extinguisher we showed you that and he
has as you can see in his other hand a
fire extinguisher to put out to picture
the players our picture was better than
the fire extinguisher you kind of have
to infer it here
this
is an aerial photograph that stated
referred to in its opening from the FBI
this is what we have it started to roll
and you'll see circles in here there's
Kelly zaminski in the green
um
and that's a thermal energy and
image they can tell I'm probably
locating their phones maybe yeah
cross-referencing yeah the one that we
have it has like a video on the side
that shows like fun footage okay oh okay
gotcha so Hans are gonna play it
so is that is that uh writtenhouse
running McGinnis Richie McGinnis and
they head down
no
no where's John Madden when you need him
he needs some snacks he's going to chase
you with a chain
from Mr sabinsky and you'll see the
flashes
of his first shots
I am not responsible for cutting this
video I don't know how I got
the way it did chopped up that's the FBI
wait what oh yeah trustworthy Source
there right it's very telling because
you'll see this a hundred times I'm not
going to go through it again for you in
opening but you'll see it that the
individuals are heading down Sheridan
Road
and
he looks like he's about to tell a dirty
joke
Mr McGinnis he looks over both shoulders
and height right in this location
you'll see Kyle come into this area and
pause where Mr and Mrs zaminski are and
you'll see in this car there's a fire
that start to see how it's bright
and they go Kyle runs in this direction
trying to get away from Mr rosenbaum's
ladies and gentlemen Kyle Rittenhouse
why aren't they showing no obligation
what why are they keeping the camera on
Kyle Rittenhouse seems like it should be
pertinent looks like he's off camera and
they can't pitch I think I got the video
he runs away from him because he doesn't
want the confrontation he doesn't want
trouble
which makes no sense
with what the state says about him
hunting maybe
oh come on he's trying to get away I'm
just guessing I don't know you'll hear
testimony not just from Kyle Rittenhouse
but Balch Mr Balch about Joseph
Rosenbaum what do you have to say yeah
and I hear you look you have a footage
or is it just what he showed Andrew Ryan
we have what he said he's not going to
show an opening statements but you can
see all right okay we do have it he's
running and he's he has at this point he
had the fire extinguisher copyright
house yeah yeah and then Rosenbaum like
hides behind a car and that's written
has passed and then he kind of circles
that's what I was saying it was very
clear they ran past him all right let's
look at the footage let's look at this
footage that they just wrote Because
here's important just for context this
is the only twit this is the prestige
that the prosecuting attorneys brought
remember they said I don't remember the
exact words we have FBI footage from a
plane that was has not been available to
the public in other words they were
saying something expecting it turns out
it's actually available well you know
what the FBI isn't necessarily airtight
with their confidential information
these days
it's not exactly a food saver so
it's not prosecuting attorney who's just
like uh oh and he just he's like
watching the trick at in the prestige
he looks on his pager because he's in
Kenosha
that's all I had
here's the FBI footage that shows Kyle
Rittenhouse hunting Mr Rosenbaum and by
the way he also uh planted on Mr
Rosenbaum a giant chain and criminal
pedophile record so here you go here's
the FBI footage okay so that is Miss
kiss
okay
ritten house or Rosenbaum sorry so that
shows them running
Kelly zaminski this is uh so footage
that also shows us side by side
this is how they're piecing together who
it is so writtenhouse wasn't chasing
resin no he has a fire extinguisher
right
so there's a reason there's Rosenbaum
coming up from behind him
you won't do yeah
yeah yeah you want to so in other words
he's chasing him because he had the gall
to put out a fire and a dumpster near a
gas station so I love my work in other
words
the serial criminal was infuriated that
another crime had been thwarted he's
like Mr Freeze no
no right so so literally Rittenhouse
runs up with a fire extinguisher the the
state was characterizing that as chasing
his face right that's not what happened
at all he runs up to the car that you
can see clearly is on fire there and
it's probably about to start putting it
out and then Rosenbaum comes around and
starts was that the fire was at the
dumpster in front of the gas station
it's hard to tell that I think that was
a car lot oh so that's another place
oh a little Heat Miser he's up to those
he's up to those Shenanigans the
whole reason he was there was to protect
the car lot and so there's a car on fire
he's running down there with a fire
extinguisher and try that out it looks
like that's that's what everything looks
like then they start chasing after him
again
110. all right you see that's what we
just basically overhead view of was that
yeah right well that's what I said
earlier and I didn't have the FBI
footage but I said it's very clear he's
running past him you can see the dynamic
because he's not chasing him because
Kyle Rittenhouse runs past yeah he makes
it worse yeah the FBI makes it worse for
them because Rose and mom came around
from the car that he was sitting on fire
and Cameron is like
hey you put out my fire
yeah
these people are garbage unbelievable
absolute garbage and of course just
because someone is garbage doesn't give
you the right to take their life of
course but if someone but here's the
point if someone attacks you and
threatens to kill you while carrying a
chain and gunshots are fired and they've
committed arsony and they just so Happen
To Be A Serial child rapist so much the
better you said people don't have an
animosity against him he's wrong
that's the belief in his head and Mr
Rosenbaum chases after him
that
that will want to say why are they not
showing people down there he went down
there that's weird I think they said
they wouldn't show it in opening
statement oh that's what it was yeah why
didn't he keep running
one you don't have to run she said
you're gonna see it a hundred times
throughout them I'll show you
a video
that's what I was saying yeah back onto
the car Source lot
taken by an individual who will testify
and his daughter I believe aquafina's a
sponsor
next photograph
circled again
zaminski with the arm up Rosenbaum in
full stride chasing Point starts
drinking Ozark and someone's like no
this is the video from 63rd you want to
be found guilty
[Music]
now they cut the feed no they're showing
the they're showing the laser there they
got the audience
that is the other side so that's where
Kyle was running towards that's the
group of people on the other side of the
lot during the trial
the individuals were at car Source the
rioters
destroying all those he was answering a
call for help too yeah from Mr Rosenbaum
he did not want to run into those
rioters who were destroying all of that
property that did not belong to them
you hear the first gunshot the evidence
will show Mr zaminsky you hear four
shots in quick succession the evidence
will show that is
Kyle firing at Mr Rosenbaum as he's
trying to take Kyle's weapon from him to
use against him
you hear three more shots in quick
succession I don't think the government
will have any dispute I don't think the
evidence will dispute those three shots
are from another person who's in the car
Source lot firing
for some reason
he was never identified never arrested
this will show Kyle running back to the
scene of the shooting
and it will show I think the evidence
will show why Kyle Rittenhouse didn't
stay and render aid for Mr Rosenbaum not
that he's under any obligation to do
that but sometimes
discretion is the better part of valor
thank you
they caught the audio again you know
what and I hate this look I want to say
we believed it because of YouTube but we
won't need it on mug Club I think people
need to hear and see what's going on
this is the problem is when the media
doesn't show you what's actually
happening they whitewash it and then try
to describe it to you let me put this
shoe on the other foot for one second
let's say that Rosenbaum shaved head
Ginger
is a Serial pedophile white supremacist
let's say serial pedophile white
supremacist who committed multiple arson
fires on camera that night with a chain
yelled shoot me shoot me
three four times on camera
and a person of color shot him
do you think it would be a national
trial do you think people would be
outraged
and I say that because you will get some
in the media who are more offended by me
letting you know the words of the serial
child rapist
than they are at the idea that he's a
Serial child rapist who tried to kill
another child keep in mind a Serial
child rapist when the same argument the
left is using coverness was a minor this
is a guy who raped Miners
and was trying to physically harm
another minor yeah
oh what point does the thing think of
the children go where is that
and who in their right mind chases down
a guy with a gun
if you don't have a weapon people who
are in there right what are you doing
you lost them
but they're not intimidated it's almost
like pedophiles are sick in the head oh
well well that's not the reason they're
hospitalized no no no no that's the
reason why they're jailed and let out
immediately and you know what people say
oh what's he saying there it's it's it's
shocking the people who haven't heard it
because the media won't show it to you
but they will tell you about how long
did we have to hear that there was a
secret hidden tape of Donald Trump oh
using the n-word on The Apprentice yeah
this never came out yeah yeah I don't
remember never came out we just heard
that Paula Deen says right here on
camera a Serial pedophile who who by the
way beat the out of his spouse
couldn't go home that's why he's
homeless repeatedly fiance repeatedly
yells the n-word on camera while making
violent death threats around black
people keep in mind and a black lives
matter I'm really sorry I mean does it
get any worse well because do you think
he knew it was a black lives matter
protest or do you just think he knew it
was a right and you could join the fun
yeah well that's that's a possibility
it's a possibility I think he's a piece
of yeah
I'll say it well based on his record he
looks like a piece of that was in
fact his nickname in the mental
institution cell b for peace oh
his counselor was like you're a mess
but they're sick
they're sick on my knees I'm sorry what
is it you did
oh my gosh I'm surprised that the uh
given given how the state opened this up
I'm surprised he didn't say and he had a
chain
in his left hand
it was like it wasn't that out loud it
wasn't the biggest change I could have
been bigger there are bigger chains that
are for exist yeah for example used on
boats as anchors
um it could have been he was carrying
the chain to rope off the club from the
ugly people ring ring hold on that's
bigger than the club was burned down so
he was carrying the chain that was taken
off of his feet to be yeah
that's all come on guys I mean I feel
like he halfway through his statement
he's like well I've already started yeah
I guess just I guess I don't see the
difference between taking your blood
pressure it's got to be the most amazing
thing ever that was a crazy quote that
is insane
or if you need a kidney transplant or if
you raped a minor it's really old
friends we're all children in the eyes
of God several Miners and I mean really
some more Hellbound than others uh
mainly mainly him yeah especially after
you've attempted suicide and beaten your
uh yeah I mean really your honor come on
who Among Us why did you just say we're
all chilled in the eyes of God well I
thought that would soften the blow of
the fact that he rapes them so we're all
children in the eyes of God and we were
married in heaven before on Earth did he
marry any of these children well he
tried but uh then he just left the body
next to the chapel in Vegas because
apparently they frowned up on that kind
of thing what is he a Prophet come on
yeah exactly there's some religions that
love this sort of thing Gerald
it's a little subtle it was like I
wasn't subtle
that was the joke I was trying to find
God bless you for making all right
should we just take the rest of the
statement to mug Club do you think
tokeno oh my God we're on YouTube
we still are
all right we should have been Rumble up
this is going on forever do you want to
finish we want to let this guy finish
his statement you should say let him
finish all right I don't think you far
from the end here look at this photo
real quick Kyle's head if it had been
inches further to the left he makes
Square contact with it his head hits the
ground and the skateboard I don't know
if he dies it's a possibility he's
certainly not able to fend off any
attackers after that oh God he's he was
that close twice in five seconds to
dying I would say yeah he could die he
could have died bare hand pulling the
gun towards him
jump kickman getting up to run away I
love this name
Brian jump kick the bare hand on the gun
Kyle Rittenhouse flat on his back the
most vulnerable position one can be in
oh that's a nice wow except turned
around in a child just pulled tight
Mr Huber's trying to pull the gun away
from Kyle Rittenhouse as he's laying
flat on his back let this be a lesson to
everyone shot with his own sling your
rifle yep he fires one shot striking Mr
Huber in this photograph is he jumping
he's trying to pull the gun away from
him
right now
oh yeah he was just gonna take care and
then oh no no
my keys hands up Kyle Rittenhouse does
not fire look at the distance between
them
Huber skateboard has not even hit the
ground yet that's how fast all these
things occur I'm amazed wow the
Marksmanship
he was a hell of a painter
yeah yeah well as Hitler right and I'm
not saying I'm saying I don't even think
it's getting anything wrong but even if
you think he's the equivalent to Casey
no it can shoot I kept thinking that uh
I would have probably shot the guy eight
times already but to be honest he
probably would have had my gun yeah
here's the shielding by the way oh he
was shielding himself yeah like I said
that's there's no way his body is not
turned he's re here's the thing that arm
is reaching around because he's trying
to get an angle look here's a perfect
example because uh you can bring me back
up here real quick again the prosecuting
attorney said he was standing this way
he bladed his body
right and I'm kind of giving you a
little bit of the uh a little bit of the
Eugene yeah here here's the thing it's
the difference between a straight punch
and this is important because why why
would someone be bringing their arm
around right in other words if this is
here the only way you can shoot my bicep
is if this arm was here yeah that's a
hug yes exactly it's a nice hollow point
hug that's awesome it's a difference
between a straight punch and this is
just the physics of it right boom
straight down the middle okay
or a hook what's the reason for the hook
you throw a straight punch and someone's
blocking it your straight punches can't
get through right your guard and so you
get around the guard with a hook so the
guy wasn't bled and protecting him he
was clearly bringing this gun around to
get around the guard of Kyle
rittenhouse's gun that's all he was so
close it's a If he if calritt Nelson had
a bayonet on that gun the guy would have
impaled himself on it yeah and so he was
having to bring this hand around
to try and shoot him in the head it's
very very clear thank goodness this
isn't the first Civil War right right
well I mean they could ask Gage what
were you doing with your uh right arm
with uh he had a gun but that's
irrelevant but it was coming around here
I mean it was obviously trying to uh
subdue what was the destination where
was that yeah he was literally coming
around to point the gun at his head and
pull the trigger right that was it and I
used my thumb somebody's gonna say that
screw you yeah
just bring out his Glock and put some
lipstick on him like senior Wednesdays
hey where were you going Mr Gluck oh
and well there you have it your
honoration this is bullity the magic
luck all proud of himself walks back to
the chair he's a harmless clock I like
the Harry Potter world and I like the
turkey drumstick and Tacos
oh there's people it's just by the way I
don't think this defense attorney he's
presenting evidence I think he's doing a
great job though and presenting no part
of an argument I don't think anybody did
but he doesn't need to do a great job
he's got video evidence yeah I mean this
prosecution did that Jeff he won like
this this all happened very very fast
Tire hilarious would it be if he went to
like exhibit tea and it was just I mean
he is just doing what you should do
which is here's the video here's the
video no it's 100 true it makes sense
yeah
and everybody's like he shot somebody
and he's like I'm turning myself into
the police hands are up the problem with
that strategy a little bit is that
networks won't air the most offensive
parts of the video Yeah well of course
because it makes the other guys look bad
yeah yeah I mean it sadly
you know he's trying to win the case as
opposed to keep America from and did you
hear what that guy yeah did you hear
what that the the driver said over the
intercom he goes is are they straight
ahead are they straight ahead yeah
people that they shut yes
it's Kyle pauses yes also by the way the
same reason that the leftists out there
are saying well why didn't they shoot
these militants the police ran into them
out protecting businesses and they
didn't run up on the cops they
approached the police officers told them
what they were doing and the officers
gave them water and it was a cordial
interaction so if you've had that in
Kenosha not a big town very likely these
are the same police officers I don't
think they have a budget for a fleet of
armored vehicles they're saying oh those
were the guys earlier who were
protecting the car lot yeah yeah no we
talked to them nice guys they're not
they're not causing any problems all
right hands up and weapons slung over
your shoulder he's actually trying to
push it towards behind his back so it's
no threat at all to the officers like
come on I mean there's just because a
guy has a gun doesn't mean he's a threat
hey we know what people used to say
about the he uh in Ferguson right
Michael Brown like hands up don't shoot
him that his hands weren't up he was
punching the cop in the face and tried
to take his gun hands up this way like
what's the difference because uh Brown
was black and writtenhouse is white no
no the key part is when an officer says
hands up you put your hands up yeah
you can't start that's the primary
reason by the way if just because you
freeze frame the fist up here doesn't
mean hands up yeah okay is it's coming
in to land another blow yeah
Police Department turning themselves in
to the police which is what he wanted to
do here in Kenosha but the way Kenosha
was that night with the police
department surrounded by fans went to
the police things like that he couldn't
he turned himself into law enforcement
he said from that day what he did he's
made no
bones about that he acted in
self-defense ladies and gentlemen the
evidence will show period his actions
and it's important by the way for this
country to recognize that people have
the right to self-defense when you're
talking about billions of dollars in
Damages thousands of arrests and people
who are violently harmed during these
riots while the media cheered it on
while our current vice president cheered
it on and said it wouldn't stop and it
shouldn't stop and they need to keep
doing it guess what the right your
god-given right to self-defense to
self-preservation is important and you
know what else good for him he shouldn't
have been there really hey how come you
guys are allowed to go down and burn
down because you think the system
isn't doing enough and when a kid
actually sees the system not doing
enough to prevent people from being hurt
and their being burned down you
condemn him well what was he doing there
well how about you answer as to every
single 17 year old in the Summer of Love
with a brick
how about that let's start you go first
why were you there Burning Down the
Walgreens yeah every single time they
they make that argument it just baffles
me because the Second Amendment only the
Second Amendment can only be useful if
you can apply it right right and if you
can use it otherwise it's just words on
a piece of paper if Kyle Rittenhouse
can't go down there and defend a
business it doesn't matter whose
business it is he's standing out front
saying hey hey no no not here move on
right and somebody tries to attack him
and he cannot use his firearm to defend
himself then it's not a right yeah it's
just a cause and effective something
that you started right like look in
order to take a we feel helpless by the
system what do you mean and they go we
with Jacob Blake we felt helpless by the
system that's what black people in
Kenosha were talking to Wisconsin Right
Milwaukee rights and then it's like hold
on a second so you felt helpless because
a guy who broke a restraining order
against his baby mama who he abused and
kidnapped the kids and reached for a
knife in the car got shot you feel
helpless by the system how about the guy
who did nothing wrong and had it his
entire business and residents built to
the ground how about that
they felt helpless
the only difference is one was inflicted
by you
it was inflicted by you based on a lie
Jacob Blake
was also a criminal in the act of a
violent crime that could have gotten
more violent
this is a real problem if if Tim Poole
can talk about this and soak in the left
and I can say we are absolutely headed
to a Civil War in our time and it does
it will not look like the Civil Wars
that you have imagined in the past you
just saw actually Independence as poll
just came out today Independence uh and
Republic I think even Democrats I don't
know what it was but overall with the
general population they saw Democrats as
a greater threat to our democracy than
Republicans and that's with polls this
is what the media really doing the
bidding of Democrats right now that's a
that's a shocking statistic absolutely
and by the way keep sending in your
chats we are going to go to mug club we
are going to take chats yes we are going
to make sure you guys keep sending in
your chats is this statement done I
think he's looks like he wrapped up five
or so uh all right with that uh please
don't talk about the case during the
break
uh and uh is it unrealistic to
set a tentative start time of about
quarter after one
but if you folks want more
that's like a 41 break your arm it
sounds like a guy in uh in Jaws who was
confused when he heard tiger shark
you're the judge you tell me I know I
like this guy though he's fine yeah no I
do like him because he's kind of he's no
BS and you can tell he's seen a lot yeah
he has to MapQuest antion's pretzels
yeah that's right they close the
wall because they burned that one shoot
well Kyle defend the right stuff so look
before we go here we're gonna go to Mud
Club take your chats thank you Rumble uh
as well we want as many of you watching
on Rumble as possible because you never
know when our streams get cut out uh
like you were talking about this is this
and we'll do a segment whether it's
tomorrow the day after look
this trial is about something pretty
clear it is about the first the second
amendment yeah and by the way it's also
about the First Amendment let me be
clear with you by what I mean with that
it's about the Second Amendment in your
god-given right to bear arms not keep
them in a finger uh print coded gun safe
to keep in bear arms that means to carry
your Firearms as well uh it's also about
the First Amendment because
people on the left want to make sure
that offensive speakers aren't allowed
on college campuses we see this
everywhere uh they want people to be
removed they have stage walkouts at
Netflix because of Dave Chappelle uh but
they believe that rioting burning and
looting and I'm speaking in general
terms here but I'm speaking about the
leftist movement the leftist movement
protests Dave Chappelle the leftist
movement stages those walkouts the
leftist movement demands Justice from
the system the leftist movement starts
the rioting and looting the leftist
movement and their leaders call Chaz
chop The Summer of Love right this is
I'm making a generalization because I'm
basing it on their leaders the
overwhelming majority of their actions
not to mention all of the polling data
so it is about the First Amendment it's
about the sacrament but it's about
something else too
it truly is about
if you look at this is kind of a litmus
test
let's take race out of the equation and
you always should when you're judging an
act of morality
uh why because melanin in the skin does
not change your moral fiber or your
ability to make moral rationalizations
period whether you're black or you're
white so you look at this and you see a
kid who went down we went back through
the timeline cleaning up graffiti he was
a lifeguard he worked there he didn't
carry a gun across state lines right
people pursued him he was using a fire
extinguisher he's trying to help the
community protect the community people
with chains with nooses with guns with
skateboards try to Snuff out his life
and he defended himself and you can look
at that
and if you look at that and say hey
thank God this is not the UK thank God
this is not Canada and that child who
was being pursued by a child rapist with
a chain has the god-given right to
protect himself he can look at it that
way or you can look at it and say oh the
humanity we have a gun culture here
would have been better if he'd have been
Chained and raped on the floor you don't
know the guy who was chasing him had a
history of chaining people raping people
beating people it's not that far out of
the realm of possibility and the point
is we shouldn't have to care
that's why you have the god-given right
to self-preservation that's why you have
the god-given right to speak out and you
don't have the right to infringe on
someone else's ability to speak out look
if you look at that and you think the
Cal Rittenhouse is a terrorist or a
white supremacist you really you you
don't like the United States of America
and I say this right now conservatives
are more American than liberals what do
you mean what do I mean by that let me
tell you exactly what I mean by that
more than ever Americans want to divide
this country you've seen polls it's over
30 something percent as close as 40
percent significant portion almost a
third of Democrats who believe that we
are headed towards a situation this
world where states secede we'll do a
whole segment on this this week
if that happens okay
we have a new country now who gets to
remain the United States of America I
argue without a shadow of a doubt of
course the conservative districts of
course the conservative States well why
because you don't because you don't like
the flag you try to create a new one and
you don't like the national anthem you
created a new one bye you don't like
America you don't like the first
amendment you don't like the Second
Amendment you look at this and you say
isn't this a tragedy that a white kid
was able to defend himself from a Serial
child rapist you do not like the United
States of America you may want to live
in a place like Canada where our friends
who are comedians can be subject to a
human rights tribunal and then the
Supreme Court of Canada for a joke while
prime minister blackface does it uh he's
a blackface connoisseur and everyone
turns a blind eye you may want to live
in a country of no American flag to that
two national anthems uh black lives
matter activism doing away with the
nuclear family the destruction these are
these are not Straw Men these are
described goals demands and the black
lives matter Charter
antifa is not an idea it's a group of
people who commit acts of violence
and let's say that maybe they weren't
maybe they lost their membership card
these people in Kenosha
who are committing assault and battery
and arson on camera and even though it's
not admitted to court have a long
history of beating women strangling
women knifing women raping kids right
you couldn't you couldn't you couldn't
flick a penny without hitting a
pedophile or a wife beater or general
woman beater there let's assume that
their antifa or black lives matter card
got lost in the mail
it doesn't matter because only one side
of this country enables that and if
you secede guess what it's not the side
of the country that gets to remain the
United States of America I'll stand by
it it's a generalization leave your
comments below we are going to go to Mud
Club take your chat and uh see more
maybe about that Rittenhouse challenge
YouTube piss off